Oh, gut, moin Leute, eigentlich wollte ich heute Abend MMO Kreiselcrib machen, aber
Aber der Kreisel-Grind ist so schlecht gestartet, dass ich mir gedacht habe, ein No-Pass.
Da mach ich heute keinen Kreisel-Grind weiter.
So, wir schwätzen einfach noch ein bisschen.
Wir machen das Gleiche wie gestern.
Ich hab nix Großartiges vorbereitet, wir werden heute nix programmieren.
Wir werden uns heute kein Bastelkram angucken.
Wir gucken uns vielleicht ein paar interessante Videos zusammen an, wo es um Bastelkram geht.
Das wollen wir mal gucken.
Kein Hi-IQ-Kram? Doch, das kann schon sein.
Ha, da ist er wieder.
Da hab ich schon, da hab ich drauf gewartet.
Das kann schon Hi-IQ-Kram sein, aber muss nicht zwangsläufig.
Gucken, je nachdem, was ich so finde.
Heute das Wirtschaftsinformatiker-Video, was wir gestern nicht mehr geschafft haben.
Wir haben noch ge... Moment, du meinst das...
Das da?
Ja, wollen wir mal gucken.
Leute, guckt mal hier.
Dieses Video, ne?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendjemand gesehen hat.
Mein Video von heute.
Habt ihr es gesehen oder habt ihr es nicht gesehen?
Okay, ich geh davon aus, dass ihr es nicht gesehen habt.
Weil...
Ja, doch, einige haben es bestimmt geguckt.
Ich hab mir wirklich Mühe gegeben mit dem Video.
Der Cutter hat sich Mühe gegeben.
Also ich hab dann wieder mal jemand beauftragt, ein ordentliches Video drauf zu machen.
Es guckt keine Sau.
Das Video ist das schlechteste von allen Videos, die ich in letzter Zeit hochgeladen hab.
In den ersten, keine Ahnung, acht Stunden von der Performance.
Normalerweise bin ich bei 10.000 plus Views und jetzt bin ich bei fünf.
Also, da sieht man mal wieder, irgendwelche Videos, wo man sich Mühe gibt, lohnen sich überhaupt nicht.
Am besten wir machen einfach 08.15 Zeug und Reaction.
Einfach reacten.
Meine, ich muss Videos machen, meine Ansage an random Dudes, wo ich eigentlich überhaupt keine Ahnung hab, mich nicht interessiert.
Aber Hauptsache Ansage an.
Und dann kann, und dann reagiert er vielleicht auf meine Ansage und dann kann ich auf die Counter-Ansage von ihm eine neue Ansage machen.
Und dann...
Ich find das Video auch gut, aber es hat keiner geguckt bisher.
Wobei man sagen muss...
Langzeit...
Erfolg...
Eines Videos...
Ist nicht zwangsläufig...
Abhängig von der Performance...
In den ersten paar Stunden.
Das kann durchaus sein...
Dass das die nächsten paar Tage oder vielleicht sogar Wochen noch ganz gut wird.
Durch den Schneestelzen.
Naja gut, warum dieses Durch den Schneestelzen Video?
Schnupperleere Informatik.
Der Kerl ist 8 oder so?
Also das Durch den Schneestelzen Video weiß ich bis heute nicht, warum das überhaupt so viele Views hat.
Leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Also es geht um dieses Video...
Moment, was ist denn das?
Alter, da schreien sie rum.
Was ist denn das?
Ich hab's gerade gesehen.
Die Punkte waren doch eben rot in der...
Guck mal, gelb Kopf.
Wann gibt es da rote Punkte?
Das ist neu.
Bestimmt neue Chrome Version oder so.
Guck mal, dass die Suchbegriffe rot sind.
Was ist das denn?
Also es geht um dieses Video.
Ich habe seriously keine Ahnung, warum das auch nur ansatzweise eine Ahnung, warum das 2 Millionen Views hat.
meine normalen videos haben so sind so im dreh 20k bis 80k so in dem dreh manchmal
gibt es noch ein paar ausreißer noch besser oder meistens sind 20 bis 80k in dem dreh
manchmal auch ein bisschen aber ja alter dass das keiner will winners 11 hat 196.000 aufrufe
auf einmal warum denn das das hat am anfang kam das auch nicht so gut an
klickbait weilschneider genau wtf das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht dass das noch so eine
2634 kommentare mann war mir gar nicht so bewusst
ok
warum nicht soll mir recht sein
klickbait weilschneider weiß ich ob schnee alleine als klickbait ausreicht ich weiß nicht
heute habe ich irgendwas wichtiges verpasst heute gab es irgendwas spannendes ja es gibt
etwas spannendes also für die leute die sich für technikrams hier bei mir interessieren es
gibt tatsächlich was ihr werdet nicht glauben hat die katze abgenommen ja die katze hat abgenommen
aber die hat jetzt nicht in letzter zeit abgenommen die katze hat moment damit ihr wisst um was es geht
das ist nur einfach ein sehr günstiges foto von schicko hier das ist einfach nur günstig
günstig fotografiert die katze hat aber tatsächlich abgenommen also ich die bekommen habe hat ich
weiß gar nicht 4,5 oder so dass ich die ist ja dies ja ziemlich klein dies ja ziemlich klein
ziemlich klein und kurz so beine kurz kurzer hals und sowas die war ein bisschen dicker als
ich sie aus dem tierheim geholt habe das lag aber auch glaube ich zumindest daran weil die
ganz viel trockenfutter gefressen hat ein ganzes dach über trockenfutter gefressen so und bei mir
darf die jetzt auf die terrasse und die flitzt auch viel mehr rum und bewegt sich das hilft bei
katzen ja auch und die frisst jetzt auch normales futter zwar auch trockenfutter aber auch normales
futter und seitdem so seit so würde man sagen so ein zwei jahren oder so jetzt schon ist die
tatsächlich der ganze ecke dünner geworden jetzt jetzt nimmt sie halt nicht mehr nicht
mehr zu nicht mehr ab sonst müsste man sich ja gedanken machen ja so sieht das so sieht
das aktuell aus katzen technisch ja ich ich wiege die nicht oft ich wiege die katze immer in dem
ich mich mit ihr zusammen auf die wage stelle und danach mich alleine oder davor mich alleine
auf die wage stelle und dann wird das abgezogen quick muffs und dann weiß ich was die katze
wiegt weil alleine kriege ich die natürlich nicht auf die die wage drauf stimmt was wollte
ich erzählen genau wo bloß issues nein nicht vier champ guck mal ich habe es geschafft leute dort
falls dort falls den palzen alles klar ich habe es geschafft stellt euch vor ich habe meine dort
falls gepusht also wen es interessiert was ich für eine config in meiner linux kiste hier habe
ich ja quasi jeden stream die frage gestellt über was sie sind für alles z z schell rc zsh rc
x-server starten wim rc die git konfig das terminal der launcher der compositing der
tiling window manager starship clipboard manager ist gut wie alles drin die alten dinger die alten
dinger habe ich tatsächlich hier auch noch mal drunter gehängt also hier sind die alten
die ich da drei jahre habe rumgammeln lassen im repo als da noch irgendwas drin ist was man
braucht ich sehe ich habe die history überschrieben also history ist weg ich habe es drüber gepusht
aber ich habe die alten dort falls auf gespeichert epg champ issues da habe ich schon ewig nicht mehr
reingeguckt ich verwende den epg champ tatsächlich gibt es keine issues einer ist closed funktioniert
nicht da kann ich mich auch dran erinnern leute der typ hat nicht bei mir aufgemacht der ist
hier garantiert aus dem schrieben der an issue bei mir aus aufgemacht meinte das program startet
nicht dreimal könnt ihr raten auf welchen video ich hier rausgekommen bin die bade habe ich mich
gleich geklost los der band kratz spend habe ich nicht der epg champ hat ein neues issue gekriegt
und zwar dass irgendwelche alpha romeo sachen nicht funktionieren aber da habe ich keine ahnung
von weil ich kein auto habe von denen so sieht es aus also wie gesagt meine dort falls habe ich
heute gepusht und wenn jetzt irgendjemand fragt genau repo ist immer noch richtig wenn jetzt
irgendjemand fragt was ist das für ein prompt und warum sieht deine shell so aus und was ist
das für den window manager der alarm ist abgelaufen leute alarm da kann ich mein dort fall repo
verlinken und alles ist gut ansonsten überlege ich kann habe ich noch irgendwas spannendes verpasst
heute war irgendwas ich glaube nicht außer dass der zirkus auf twitter um das wizard game noch
immer weiter geht datenschützer nehmen letzte generation nach leck ins vizier was fragt man
sich was da genau leckt ok anscheinend heute nichts großartiges passiert ein komplett neu
email klein den nicht jeder mögen wird oh nee please leute warum warum muss mozilla ui
änderung um der ui änderung will machen ich habe schon mit firebox firefox fand ich das nicht zum
größten teil die eine gute entwicklung weil firefox auf dem desktop sich früher für mich
einfach dadurch ausgezeichnet hat dass es ein richtig schönes desktop programm war mit guter
bedienung auf dem desktop in großem funktionsumfang und kein vertappelisiertes ding hoffe das wird
jetzt hier nicht auch so gut dass man es irgendwie mit bisschen modernisieren muss verstehe ich ja
aber ich muss sagen ich finde das macht apple teilweise ganz gut teilweise nicht überall die
änderung dort sind meistens fließend und selten so richtig krasser umbruch ja das stimmt schon
ich habe mal übrigens ein iphone bestellt ich habe mir ein iphone 14 pro bestellt kein pro max
sondern ein pro in pro iphone 14 pro und zwar ich brauche ein neues iphone bzw ich brauche kein
iphone ich brauche ein smartphone bei apple hat es hieß es dass die webkit pflicht aufgehoben
wird das heißt man muss nicht mehr safari verwenden da bin ich ja mal gespannt darauf das
wäre auf jeden fall gut ja also ich musste mir ein neues smartphone kaufen weil ich wechsle
ja bald den arbeitgeber und ich nehme meine telefonnummer mit ich habe ja aktuell einen
arbeitgeber ein handy von meinem arbeitgeber und ich habe einen tarif ein handytarif von denen und
ich wechsle jetzt ja und ich habe dort die das das angefragt ob ich die ruftnummer mitnehmen
könnte die schalten das jetzt frei das heißt ich brauche ein eigenes handy in eigenen eigenen tarif
kann ruftnummer mitnahme machen und da habe ich mich halt wieder für ein iphone entschieden weil
ich hatte jetzt seit acht jahren oder so ein iphone ehrlich gesagt ich hatte auch genug
android geräte also bevor jetzt wenn irgendeiner anfängt so ist viel besser und du kannst das
überhaupt nicht vergleichen doch doch ich kann das vergleichen ich hatte und ich habe genug android
geräte um das vergleichen zu können und ich habe nichts also ich würde auch wahrscheinlich
mit dem android den täglichen benutzen klarkommen aber ich bin zu faul mich umzugewöhnen und ich
finde das apple macht das eigentlich ganz gut was gefällt ihr besser das kann ich ganz klar sagen
was mir besser gefällt aber es gibt da keine ultimative antwort es gibt bloß eine antwort
für teilbereiche also so zum täglichen benutzen gefällt mir persönlich ios smartphone wir reden
nicht von tablets wobei auf den tablets finde ich stellt sich die frage nicht wirklich finde
gerade auf tablets ist ios viel viel angenehmer als android also reden wir reden mal von von
smartphones also ich finde im täglichen benutzen finde ich ios bzw. ein iphone angenehmer sobald
es aber um das thema automatisierung geht oder ein bisschen advancedere sachen machen die sich so
der hersteller nicht eins zu eins gedacht hat ist android viel viel besser also machen wir mal ein
beispiel wenn ich zum beispiel möchte dass wenn ich zu hause im wlan bin und es bei mir an der
tür klingelt dass ich dann den anrufer bei mir auf dem handy sehe dann geht das unter ios nur
wenn ich entweder eine eigene app benutze vom hersteller der tür gegensprecheranlage oder
dass irgendwie über sieb tunnel oder sonst was und unter android ist es relativ einfach zum
beispiel mit tasker oder irgendwelchen anderen automatisierungstools mein tasker tasker ist
ja eh das geilste wobei es auch noch andere gute automatisierung sachen gibt für android da kannst
du zum beispiel so sachen machen wie lausche an einem mqtt server und wenn dort eine message mit
xy drin kommt dann anlocke den screen und switcher auf die und die app das ist mega nice also
automatisierungskram und halt sachen machen die der hersteller so nicht eins zu eins sich im
vorfeld gedacht hat ist android einfach meilenweit voraus vom technischen ansatz her was unterstützt
mit an technologien gerade wenn man sich safari anguckt muss ich sagen ist android auch vorne
raus weil safari ist ein absoluter shit browser man für die täglichen sachen gehts aber was
unterstützung von webstandards angeht und ein moderner browser ist safari nicht wirklich
ja und das ist es halt für tägliche benutzung bevorzuge ich den iphone für advancedere sachen
an eindeutig den android es gibt bald einen nativen firefox für iphone das heißt mein video
ist nicht mehr aktuell chrome auf ios existiert nicht ich zeige euch wieso leute hier ist der
max und ich muss ja heißt dass das video ist jetzt ist jetzt outdated overrated jebaited
ich benutze alles von apple er kann es ja machen benutzt du auch apple pay wahrscheinlich
alles von apple benutzt überweist du halt auch apple apple öfters mal kohle aber gut man kann
sich jeder überlegen was er machen will moin holy luck gamers das ist jetzt outdated overrated
jebaited das video demnächst kam das kam das heute auf ok chrome ios gab es da heute irgendwelche
google ist bildung war der titel wieder mann firefox der hude ziller was auch was ok firefox
and chrome might appear on ios ja das ehrlich gesagt das würde ios mal ganz gut tun wobei
so wie ich so wie ich apple kenne wird es wahrscheinlich so beschränkt sein dass es
wieder am ende keinen sinn ergibt so nach dem motto ihr dürft zwar euren eigenen browser
oder ihr eure eigene browser engine machen aber die darf nicht mehr können als safari
oder sowas 100 pro gibt es da wieder so ganz weird champige apple forgaben so dass es dann
am ende gar nichts bringt das wäre auch merkwürdig wenn ich also so ist das so ist das unter
ios beziehungsweise ist das mit apple eigentlich immer es wäre auf jeden fall gut es wäre
wunderbar wenn es noch mehr browser geben würde auf ios als safari natürlich wird
apple sagen es gefährdet die sicherheit laut apple gefährdet ja alles die sicherheit außer
wenn apple selbst das macht dann natürlich nicht
you block origin auf dem iphone ja das blöde ist dass es halt in apps nicht funktionieren
wird wenn wir mal so apps wie beispielsweise wie ist das youtube ding wenz youtube wenz
wobei wird das nicht wurde das nicht eingestellt sogar oder pipe pipe wie ist wie ist diese
youtube app für für android es gab einmal wenz und es gab pipe pipe noch irgendwas so
das gibt es ja für ios nicht wird auch apple nicht nicht zulassen und seit lohn kann man
ja auch nicht gescheit unter ios weil sich dann auch wieder löscht nach ein paar tagen
und sowas das ist auf jeden fall aber eine gute entwicklung gerade um modernere sachen
zu unterstützen new pipe genau das meine ich ich könnte mir aber halt vorstellen dass
die auch so dinger wie pwas und sowas nicht richtig anbieten dürfen so nach dem motto
und pwas muss weiterhin safari benutzen und sowas weil dann würde man ja auf einmal auf
ios apps installieren können die nicht also nicht nicht nicht komplett abs aber für die
meisten ausreichende apps dann würde mir auf einmal apps installieren können und ios
die nicht aus dem apple app store kommen und ich mein pwas unterstützt safari jetzt schon
allerdings unterstützt safari ganz viele sachen aus pwas nicht beispielsweise heißen auch
einige javascript funktionen und sowas anders anders unter safari was safari bis heute zum
beispiel nicht unterstützt sind web notifications also spricht dass man nachrichten anzeigen
lassen kann von webseiten beziehungsweise voll auf pwas so dass so das letzte große
feature wo man sagen würde hey das wäre schon sehr sehr praktisch wenn das eine pwas
auch könnte unter android geht das übrigens seit jahren schon ja das geht kann sich auch
offiziell unter ios einen adblocker installieren das geht allerdings bringt dir das halt in
den apps nix und ich finde gerade youtube lässt sich eben nicht gescheit im browser mobile
bedienen im vergleich zur app app ist viel angenehmer genauso wie twitch oder reddit
reddit macht ja auch alles dass ihre anwendung im browser mobile browser nicht ordentlich
funktioniert ja das ist ist halt doof dass es diesen workaround braucht aber es ist
gut dass es halbwegs funktioniert kann man eigentlich sein iphone auf viren überprüfen
mit einer software aber ich habe keine ahnung ich habe noch nie mein iphone auf viren überprüfen
aber der brave browser ist ja auch ein safari muss man ja sagen also das steht zwar brave
browser dran aber es ist ein safari unter ios wenn du einen vps aufsetzen würdest worauf
würdest du achten dass es günstig ist moment was ich glaube ich verstehe unter der abkürzung
kann was anderes wenn du einen vps aufsetzen worauf würdest du achten also eine app auf
ein droplet mit database und restbox 2 ja doch du meinst eine vm du meinst du meinst
eine vm worauf ich achten würde ja dass es dass es günstig ist also wahrscheinlich würde
ich zu hetzner gehen weil ich mit hetzner gute erfahrungen gemacht habe weil mich hetzner
sponsort manchmal und weil ich normalerweise eigentlich auch in hetzner gutscheincode habe
der aber irgendwie nicht mal funktioniert aber ich privat auch hetzner benutze und ich
das ganz gut finde hetzner ist preisleistungsmäßig nice mein hetzner ist jetzt nicht zu verkleiden
weil die haben jetzt kein manage kubernetes oder sowas in der richtung also da musst du
schon zu den anderen zu größeren cloud anbietern oder zu digital ocean gehen oder wenn du jetzt
irgendwie was ganz ausgefallenes brauchst aber für vms für vms ist hetzner gut ungünstig
sing ist dead ja das höre ich auch immer aber ich habe ja weder also im sing account
habe ich gar nicht link in account habe ich allerdings mein link in account ist fake linked
in mal gucken ob sie noch gibt hier guck mal da gibt sie noch meine augen
warum ist jetzt auf einmal eine paywall da eben war die noch nicht da eigentlich keine
paywall login login die seite ist einfach abfuck extrem ich hasse die link in seite
man ja also ich habe nur den fake account sing habe ich erst gar nicht angelegt aber
wenn du von null auf eine app anfangen würdest auf einer vor allem wo würdest du darauf
achten als sowas wie ein reverse proxy nee denn reverse proxy hat ja mit einer app nichts
zu tun den kannst du dir immer vorstellen reverse proxy let's decrypt zertifikate sowas
das ist ja relativ unabhängig von deiner app solange es sich nur um htp traffic handelt
ich würde die app ganz normal entwickeln mit den besten technologien für die app
was ich da was ich halt mit der app machen will was ich damit bezwecken will ansonsten
musst du du musst deine app nicht irgendwie explizit für eine vm in der cloud entwickeln
das ist das läuft alles drauf sind ganz normales linux weil du solltest irgendwas machen du
solltest jetzt vielleicht keine ies web anwendung programmieren wenn es unser linux laufen
lassen willst aber wer macht sowas heutzutage schon hat jemand von euch die auf der arbeit
die problematik dass er eine ies app supporten muss also wer es nicht weiß ies ist der wie
heißt das ding internet information service das ist ein webserver von microsoft den eigentlich
niemand der noch bei verstand ist benutzt
richtig monka es also du musst dir da eigentlich keine großen gedanken machen das läuft alles
auf einer cloud vm
es ist abartig ja du hast einen partner der darauf neue anwendung gebaut es gibt wirklich
leute die bauen ies anwendung in 2023 oder 2022 es gibt sachen die werde ich nicht verstehen
ehrlich gesagt das ein näher moment prtg ist ja auch schon 15 jahre alt oder so warum
die das nicht auf linux laufe ich mache keine ahnung gut wahrscheinlich zuviel windows windows
eigen crap ok ja keine ahnung warum man wirklich was auf es basis entwickelt ich kann eh nicht
verstehen warum man was heutzutage entwickelt was windows only ist also ich rede jetzt nicht
von desktop anwendung und spielen sondern irgendwelche server anwendung warum man da
irgendwas entwickelt was windows only ist das verstehe ich nicht ich meine es gibt
ja auch microsoft sql server für linux benutzt das jemand ernst gemeinte frage benutzt jemand
von euch oder kennt jemand von euch einen der microsoft sql oder microsoft sequel wie
manche leute sagen würden unter linux benutzt also mir ist da bisher noch nie was untergekommen
in den letzten jahren bist du gerade im resturlaub nein nein nein ich habe kein resturlaub resturlaub
also doch ich habe resturlaub aber ich habe nur sechs tage resturlaub die habe ich dann
hier also um 22 fällt bei mir der hammer 22 ist letzter arbeitstag ich habe jetzt erst
mal neuen ausweis beantragt weil mein alter abgelaufen ist weil ich brauche für meinen
neuen job leute stellt euch vor ein polizeiliches führungszeugnis aber das ist nicht schlimm
da steht dann drinnen herr max über herr max ist nichts bekannt liegen keine einträge
vor nur dass es wahnsinnig wichtig aussieht du benutzt das privat aber nicht auf linux
oder ist das nicht normal wenn man sich bewirbt nö bei den meisten brauchst du das nicht
leute ich habe nicht vor und wieder den ganzen tag chat zu lesen sage ich gleich wir gucken
uns heute ein paar interessante videos anwärme interessante videos finden aber das beantworte
ich jetzt noch doch sql express in docker unter linux ei warum macht man dann so was
enki moin so also wenn ich eine app auf so ein cloud provider hochziehen würde also
in einer vm dann würde ich da gegebenenfalls die firewall anpassen ja das ist etwas ist
immer sinnvoll ein engine x so also als eine art gateway und für ssl zertifikat ja das
ist auch sinnvoll und dann auf derselben instanz dahinter dann meine eigentliche backend app
sagst du den engine x brauche ich gar nicht das kommt auf deine app an aber ich finde
sinnvoll ich ich persönlich für die also ich mag für solche also engine x ist super engine
x ist wahrscheinlich sogar so so der no no brain entscheidung ich mag allerdings für
einfache sachen tatsächlich den hier weil da hat es letzte encrypten alles schon eingebaut
da musste nichts extra machen den brauchst du davor eine zeile in der config eintragen
und fertig den finde ich ganz gut aber ansonsten ja so kann man das machen kann es natürlich
auch direkt deine app ins internet stellen und da irgendwie ssl zertifikate machen aber
reverse proxy davor finde ich persönlich ganz angenehm spooki musik was du auch machen
kannst es wenn du zu dem cloud provider gehst oder sagen wir mal du gehst zu hetzer du könntest
das auch hetzer komplett machen lassen du könntest ja auch ein lockers alter warum ist das so
so grell die ganzen seiten mensch ah please ist ja anstrengend richtig flash bang also
du könntest auch den let's encrypt und load balancing und reverse proxy part übernehmen
lassen von hetzer zum beispiel da kannst du dir zum beispiel einen load balancer ss service
quasi holen den stellst du davor das geht dann braucht deine vm auch keine public ip
im internet dann brauchst du auch keine firewall regeln oder sowas dann kannst du so einstellen
dass die quasi nur erreichbar ist über port keine ahnung über über die interne ip port
80 und der load balancer steht im hinter das kannst du machen musst du halt mal gucken
ob sich das preislich für dich lohnt je nachdem was du da laufen lassen willst aber es auf
jeden fall eine gute idee spätestens wenn du vielleicht mal dein back end ein bisschen
skalieren können möchtest also wenn du auch mal sagen sagen willst okay ich möchte jetzt
eine neue version deployen ohne dass der service ausfällt oder möglichst gering halten dass
du sagst okay ich habe zwei drei application server kann ich einen von runter fahren und
sowas dann ist natürlich so ein managed load balancer davor eine super geschichte kann
man auch alles selbst machen mit ha proxy zum beispiel ich vermute mal sogar dass es
eine ha proxy ist auch mein bauchgefühl sagt es könnte von hetzer auch eine ha proxy sein
was die einsetzen ich weiß es nicht können aber was anderes sein die load balancer können
auch keine firewall die müssen auch gar keine firewall können weil dein server keine public
ip braucht du schaltest einfach nur das ein was du brauchst und gut ist du brauchst keine
firewall das ist per default dicht also sowas kannst du zum beispiel nehmen da wird sie
dir dann nimmst den load balancer und packst dir cloud pricing und packst dir dann so eine
kiste kannst du übrigens auch ohne du kannst übrigens auch komplett ohne public ip machen
mittlerweile oder ipv6 und ipv4 allerdings aber du kannst auch komplett ohne public ip
machen und da kannst du dir dann zum beispiel sowas hier mieten ich persönlich finde den
hier gut ich persönlich finde den hier gut triple core triple core ach mittlerweile ist
es alles amd ok nice triple core 4 gigabyte ram 80 g ssd und 20 terabyte traffic inklusive
wobei man sagen muss bei hetzer ist das so dass traffic unlimited ist in mir gar nicht
sicher ob es eingehen oder ausgehender traffic ist also das ist nicht traffic insgesamt
das ist nur traffic in eine richtung die besteht die hier drunter fällt die andere richtung
ist unlimited ja also das ist eigentlich eine gute kombination wenn du in wenn du was kleines
bauen willst brauchst du kein dedicated load balancer davor da machst du so wie du gesagt
hast du nimmst dir eine kleine kiste machst gerade mit dem reverse proxy davor und fertig ist du
kannst das stimmt stimmt chat korrekt du kannst dann da auch die firewall verwenden im web ui
dass du nur ssh und web request freigibt das ist relativ simpel du kommst du kommst du schnell rein
je nachdem was du machen willst also du kannst dir den engine ich sparen wenn du den den
managed load balancer verwenden willst ansonsten warst du in engine x oder den kadi oder irgendwas
traffic kann meinetwegen auch eine proxy sein sogar in apache ist eigentlich egal in den reverse
proxy ich mag kadi weil kadi letzten crypt eingebaut hat und total simpel aufzusetzen ist strengst du
dich auf der arbeit noch an wenn du sowieso könne ich oder machst du eher entspannen leute
ich bin so extrem unmotiviert ich mache fast gar nichts mehr ich sage euch jetzt wie sie ist ich
muss euch kein mist erzählen ich bin ich bin hyper unmotiviert was zu machen ich sitze meine
zeit ab im endeffekt übergeben noch ein paar sachen aber im größten teil ohne scheiß ich
mache nix kannst du sehr lohnt sich das auf youtube ja die kenne ich die gucken wir sogar
hier öfters im stream zusammen ok kann man vielleicht nachher gucken aber ist aber man hat
eigentlich mehr oder weniger alles gesehen was es geht und ein video dazu dass es eigentlich gar
kein chrome sondern nur safari auf ios gibt habe ich auch schon gemacht wenn der load balancer
ausfällt ist aus das ist richtig aber du hast ja den managed load balancer das heißt du kannst
auf andere leute schimpfen wenn er ausfällt du bist nicht selbst dran schuld kannst sagen mensch
ist das scheiße euer load balancer ist kaputt kannst du sagen ich kann da nichts dafür mein
service ist perfekt aber das scheiß load balancer vom anbieter ist kaputt ihr werdet lachen im
business enterprise umfeld ist das eines der hauptgründe warum man die sachen auslagert
damit man auf den finger auf jemand anderes zeigen kann wer dran schuld ist
wenn du gerade erst anfängst ich weiß ja nicht mit was du anfängst mit linux
oder mit anwendungsentwicklung wenn du gerade erst anfängst was zu programmieren warum lässt
es nicht einfach bei dir lokal laufen ich meine du kannst bei dir lokal auch alles ausprobieren du
brauchst das nicht public im internet laufen zu lassen ja hätte wenn ich einer de dost das koste
dich nichts bei hätte extra ja den traffic aber 20 terabyte traffic lasse ich erst mal 20 terabyte
de dosten höchstwahrscheinlich kommt das noch nicht mal bis bis dahin durch sommer vor schon
ein abgang da würde ich mir jetzt keine gedanken drüber machen ich würde übrigens auch schon
gedost mehrfach sogar im stream schon auf system wo ich mich hier eingeloggt habe wenn ich im
stream was mache sieht man die public ip von dem system das ist nicht schlimm da passiert nichts
aus dem warum sollten die nicht de dosten gibt es einen grund das anzunehmen ging ja nicht darum ob
man das machen sollte sondern nur dass man das machen kann ich würde es auch nicht machen ich
persönlich mark hatte als reverse proxy so wird es wahrscheinlich bei mir auch laufen
wenn du dir einen neuen laptop kaufen müsstest würdest du ein macbook nehmen für apple silicon
nee ich würde mir gar kein apple notebook kaufen weil ich täglich weil ich nicht täglich mit apple
arbeite uns auch nicht vorhabe aber wenn ich im apple ökosystem zu hause wäre vielleicht keine
ach so ja die leute wenn ich random de dost gibt auch keiner geld aus für den
random de dost die wollen damit irgendwas bezwecken also es sagt heute keiner ich
scanne mal kurz ein paar lp ranges aber es braucht 80 offen ich de dosten jetzt mal also
ganz ohne hintergedanken wozu du kannst ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel falsch machen wenn du jetzt
den linux vm dir in der cloud machst das einzige wo ich am anfang darauf achten würde ist mach
direkt gleich ssh key authentifizierung da brauchst du nämlich keine passwörter mehr eingeben und
es ist sicher und du musst auch nicht irgendwie eine große aktion machen zum konfigurieren du
musst einmal quasi den ssh public key hinterlegen und das kannst du dann beim server setup direkt
auswählen dass dieser ssh key eingetragen werden soll beim server fertig das ist vielleicht das
einzige und dann ist der server von haus aus erstmal sicher weil es ist ja nichts drauf es
läuft ja nichts drauf es läuft nur ssh drauf und nur erlaubt ssh mit deinem key so und dann
kann eigentlich nichts passieren und das nächste was du machen kannst ist entweder ufw einschalten
wenn es nur bunto kiste ist und ssh freigeben also es ist so ein command line interface für
die linux für die linux firewall oder du stellst die firewall du stellst eine firewall regel im
im web interface bei hetzner ein wobei man sagen muss du brauchst nicht unbedingt eine firewall
standardmäßig wenn du da nur dienste laufen hast die du auch anbieten möchtest ist es nicht so
wichtig also wenn du nur port 22 und port 80 offen hast oder port 443 port 22 offen hast also
nehmen wir es offen nur nur dort anwendung laufen hast da brauchst du gar keine firewall weil die
willst ja beide von außen erreichen können also kannst du eigentlich nicht so viel nicht so viel
verkehrt machen ist ein reverse proxy gleich einem load balancer nee aber es gibt schon es gibt schon
viele überschneidungen aber von der ideen ist es was anderes ein reverse proxy und load balancer
sind zwar beides sagen wir sagen wir mal ein eingang zu einem dahinter liegenden service wobei
es beim load balancer eher um die reine lastverteilung geht also gibt es ja mehrere
mehrere philosophien wie man das machen kann zum beispiel anhand von connections bisschen
advanced anhand von auslastungen oder aber auch einfach abwechselnd jede connection auf welchen
server das nächste was load balancer vielleicht noch ein bisschen können ist sticky sessions das
wenn quasi der client zum ersten mal anfragt dass sich der load balancer das merkt wohin er
load balancer hat und weitere verbindung quasi immer zum gleichen service kommen und reverse
proxy ist eher was wenn du requests umschreiben willst oder und auch wenn du sowas wie letzten
kripp machen willst davor wobei letzten kripp auch auf load auch für load balancer sinnvoll
ist als ssl terminierung es ist ein bisschen an unterschiedliche anwendungszweck aber im
kern ist es viele überschneidung deswegen kannst du auch oftmals load balancer als reverse proxy
verwendet und reverse proxy als load balancer also kannst zum beispiel bei ha proxy oder so ha proxy
heißt zwar schon ha proxy aber ist hauptsächlich eher als htp load balancer im einsatz macht aber
auch ssl terminierung und letzten kripp wobei er letzten kripp nicht eingebaut es gibt gibt
viele überschneidung der hauptsächliche unterschied auf technischer ebene kaddi kann das auch also
die reine lehre würde ich sagen ist der unterschied folgender ein load balancer kümmert sich
hauptsächlich um bis zu layer 4 also der nimmt tcp verbindung an wenn man sowas wie ha proxy
hat was hat ttp load balancer dann ist schon wieder aber noch ein von der reinen lehre würde ich
sagen ein load balancer kümmert sich bis layer 4 also load balancer verteilt tcp verbindung auf
unterschiedliche backends egal ob da hatte tp drüber gemacht hat oder was anderes und ein
reverse proxy versteht was drüber geht und kann zum beispiel auch requests umschreiben die reinkommen
wobei man halt wie gesagt sagen muss in der praxis ist das oftmals das gleiche tool was beides macht
also beispielsweise so ein managed hetzener cloud lb das ist load balancer und reverse proxy in einem
kennt jemand traffic ja klar traffic ist auch nice wobei ich traffic stand alone nicht mag
traffic ist gut in verbindung beispielsweise mit autodiscovery von docker container oder
cluster services wo es irgendwie irgendwelche discovery möglichkeiten gibt traffic konflikt
von hand ist kacke muss man einfach so sagen finde ich finde ich eklig aber mit autodiscovery
und service discovery ist traffic sehr nice die p-server verwendet halt keiner mehr leute
wann habt ihr zuletzt fdp-server verwendet ich habe die letzten zehn jahre glaube ich
kann fdp-server mal verwenden eklig seriously leute was war es bei euch los also scp benutze
ich öfters zum rüber kopieren aber fdp was macht ihr denn mit dem fdp-server ok
dateien übertragen aber warum muss das fdp sein also was ist der hintergrund seid ihr bei
irgendeinem seid ihr bei irgendeinem billigen klau bei irgendeinem billigen hosting anbieter
der nur fdp zugriff hat oder so oder was oder wie man verwenden ich habe ewig kein fdp
verwendet kann man auch mac os in der cloud hosten gut du kannst mac os in vms laufen
lassen also kannst du es auch in der cloud hosten wobei nicht zwangsläufig manchmal
brauchst du patches und es geht nicht also ja theoretisch kannst du es gibt sogar anbieter
die die bieten virtualisierte meck-kisten-kisten an es ist auf jeden fall schwieriger mac os
in der cloud laufen zu lassen als beispielsweise linux oder windows ja fällt mir jetzt auch
nicht ein
aws ist immer noch der größte klau wobei es könnte sein dass ich miss erzählt aber
ich glaube aws ist immer noch der größte klau anbieter aws ist schon ok nur die benahmung
bei aws blickt keiner durch was was ist ich glaube es ist korrigiert mich wenn ich falsch
liege ich glaube es ist aws größer asher größer google cloud ich bin mir da nicht
ganz sicher aber ich glaube aws ist immer noch der meist benutzte anbieter
cloud press ist es vollkommen egal wie du die dateien überträgst
welche anwendungsfall haben denn mac server ja das ist auch das erste was mir einfallen
würde irgendwelche ios mac apps und sowas ok leute so komm wir gucken uns jetzt mal ein
bisschen was an was haben wir denn schönes die harte realität als software entwickler
ok warum warum linux da sind wir doch gerade beim thema leute warum linux schöner ist
als mac os und windows da bin ich ja mal gespannt arch by the way also ich ehrlich gesagt ich
würde sagen es ist vielleicht es ist die frage was man schön schön ansieht also sagen
wir mal rein vom ästhetischen designer kram gibt es bestimmt linux distribution und bestimmt
auch einzelne leute die sich da was designen was durchaus mithalten kann was apple macht
wobei man schon anerkennen muss mac os ist ziemlich gut aus einem guss ja auch das viele
shortcuts über app übergreifend gleich sind und sowas also mac os macht schon einen eindruck
ziemlich aus einem guss das für mich negative was damit einhergeht ist jedes mac os ist
exakt gleich also da ist nicht viel customize und im prinzip sieht jedes mac os auch überall
exakt aus wie mac os und sonst nichts anderes habe ich glaube ich könnte sein dass wir
mal ausprobiert haben kann ich mich aber nicht mehr dran erinnern so und das schöne das schöne
an linux ist für mich nicht unbedingt so sehr wie ich sie gemacht habe die rein die optik
sondern dass ich machen kann was ich will und vor allem dass mir nichts in weg kommt
und mir nichts auf den sack geht das ist für mich ganz wichtig deswegen habe ich ja auch
so ein minimalistisches setup ich meine ich habe drei workspaces ein browser im fullscreen
ein terminal im fullscreen und ein editor im fullscreen fertig und noch dann sechs weitere
workspaces die ich verwenden könnte aber das war es mehr brauche ich nicht ok das
heißt das bin ich mal gespannt nee ich bin heute zu kaputt irgendwas zu machen ich wollte
heute eigentlich auch mmo kreisel grind machen aber das ging nicht weil irgendwie nichts
richtig los war und das kacke gelaufen ist so schauen wir mal gibt es einen link für
den wallpaper nee aber bald weil ich habe bei meinem thumbnail designer beauftragt dass
er uns white paper happy background bastelt für unterschiedliche tageszeiten so white
paper happy mit sterne am himmel und pyjama an white paper happy mit zahnbürste und frühstück
und sowas gibt es dann sieben acht verschiedene white paper happy backgrounds die man dann
quasi tageszeit abhängig in den hintergrund machen kann warum ist ein chrome logo unten
blau weil es chromium ist und das chrome bist du kaffee trinker ich trinke kaffee aber nicht
oft also ich bin niemand der morgens nicht erstmal kaffee reinhauen muss also gucken
wir uns jetzt mal an warum linux schöner ist als mccall da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt
was die ct dazu zu sagen hat da muss man mal gucken also meine meine ansicht der dinge
habe ich euch ja gerade schon erklärt hier so cool können betriebssystem des torps aussehen
ja und so kacke können task leisten sein wir unter bin aus elf ich lehne mich jetzt mal
ganz weit aus dem fenster und sagt ich finde das hier optisch frischer als windows oder
mac os vor allem weil das halt wirklich wie computer also ich muss sagen das fresheste
ist immer noch ein i3 wo alles einfach im fullscreen ist und man seine ruhe hat und
natürlich das allerwichtigste ein ein white paper happy im background leicht durchschimmern
bei 97 prozent transparent ja moment mittlerweile sieht ja wird gar nicht mehr so aus sondern
es sieht jetzt noch genauso aus nur dass alles flach ist es sieht nicht mehr so aus es sieht
vom style also aus nur dass alles flach ist versichert können ihr euch noch dran erinnern
wie das damals gehatet wurde mit den ribbon bars ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich bin da
bis heute noch nicht so richtig warm damit geworden aber es ist schon es ist schon ganz
okay habe ich euch eigentlich erzählt dass ich mir privat den office 365 aber gekauft
habe ich weiß auch nicht was mich da geritten hat drei mal ja okay habe ich schon erzählt
ja ja wie gesagt ich bin immer noch der meinung man braucht eigentlich kein office aber wisst
ihr wisst ihr was der grund ist wahrscheinlich halte ich mich für bescheuert aber der grund
ist tatsächlich powerpoint da kann man mittlerweile echt paar ganz coole sachen machen und das
ist halt im business umfeld sehr beliebt ich verwende nach wie vor kein wort und sonstige
sachen morph zum beispiel ist sehr nice in powerpoint ja genau aber tatsächlich der
einzige grund gut und weil es in zwei terabyte online speicher dabei gibt das auch ist auch
nice und so billig kriegst du sonst kein zwei terabyte online speicher was würdest du alternativ
zu office benutzen naja das was ich die letzten zehn jahre über benutzt hat benutzt habe
gar kein office ich hatte lieber office installiert habe ich aber so gut wie nicht benutzt gar
kein office den text editor mit markdown drin und wenn man es braucht als pdf von html rendern
easy was das kostet es ist relativ günstig ist relativ günstig ihr compare all plans
ja hier 69 dollar im jahr 70 70 dollar im jahr ach sorry nicht zwei terabyte cloud storage
ein terabyte cloud storage habe ich verguckt ich bilde mir ein es waren mal zwei terabyte
cloud storage aber das ist letztendlich wurscht es geht ja auch um das um das gesamtpaket
und das finde ich tatsächlich ganz gut so dieses dass man von überall bearbeiten kann
nein ich will nicht chatten mit euch wie penetrant diese webseiten mittlerweile sind mensch dass
man von überall arbeiten kann ist auch ganz nice wie gesagt ich bin ja kein fan davon
unbedingt jetzt die privatesten sachen in die cloud zu packen aber wenn man jetzt zum
beispiel an einem powerpoint krempel arbeitet wo jetzt nichts super secret drinne steht kann
man das ja durchaus benutzen also wie gesagt ich ich habe es mir gekauft mal gucken ob
ich es verlänger ok wo sind wir stehen geblieben also ok warum linux schöner ist als mac os
und windows auf gehts polisen drauf designed oder business pläne oder steuererklärung
also jetzt nix gegen solche sachen es gibt halt einfach leute die wollen gerne an geräten
arbeiten die so wenig wie möglich wie computer wirken aber es gibt auch leute die mögen
computer und technik und ja und diese leute die benutzen als bildschirm schon auch ascii
aquarium beste sogar kommando zeilen und für die ist linux kommando zeile ist das beste
was es gibt das einzige problem ist dass die ganzen leute unter windows cmd kennen und cmd
ist halt absoluter krepp und deswegen denken sie kommando zeile ist krepp hey ist das ist
ist das der typ aus dem meme i putz und dings in your dings and now dings in dings ich weiß
gar nicht wie das original meme geht joe dork joe dork i putz irgendwas ja das ist ja
ich und parallel unser video producer schahin haben zum ersten mal seit vielen jahren linux
auf unseren hauptrechnern installiert und das als tägliches das habe ich so habe ich
auch wobei habe ich auch wiederum nicht ich habe es auf dem zweiten desktop einfach am
start also auf dem unter windows halt am start dabei hatten wir viele sehr aufregende erlebenisse
wie schnell ging das jetzt das steam alle windows spiele kann alter wo ist jetzt der unterschied
zwischen desktop und fenster manager bleibt dran liebe internet surfer herzlich willkommen
intro immer man dieses video wird gesponnen von only office only office ist ein online
office zur sicheren bearbeitung gerade ein linux video wo noch nix über open source freies
software trojaner böse riesenkonzerne gesagt wurde sondern einfach nur dass linux cooler
aussieht als andere betriebssysteme denn irgendwie finden wir das ein bisschen langweilig dass
linux immer nur in die eine ecke gedrängt wird inzwischen hat es auch ganz viele andere
vorteile die gar nichts mit irgendwelchen politischen vorstellungen alle spiele ist
überzogen ja das stimmt ich bin ja da auch immer kritisch was gaming unter linux angeht
es geht ja wirklich viel mittlerweile und ich habe die gesamte entwicklung mitgemacht seit
den anfängen von wine und die geschichte mit only office und und wobei war das nicht
hier sogar nur doch ist das sogar only office ja mit das ist ja quasi ein wine fork für
für zeug also ich habe die ganzen sachen mitgemacht es tut wirklich viel mittlerweile es gibt aber
auch viel was nicht tut und das einzig doof daran ist dass wenn man wirklich ein interessierter
gamer ist und auch sich sich mal auf steam einloggen will und wenn ein neues release ist und sich
neu release kaufen und einfach los spielen da hast du halt immer so ein bisschen das problem dass du
nicht weißt ob es funktioniert ja anti cheat kannst du komplett vergessen kommt darauf an wenn
der hersteller mitmacht geht das also bettel bettel ei soll mittlerweile besser sein ja und die ganze
valve anti cheat geschichte aber du kannst kein rainbow 6 spielen ich glaube ipac soll auch demnächst
gehen habe ich gelesen aber rainbow 6 kannst du vergessen fortnight kannst du vergessen kot
kannst wahrscheinlich auch vergessen overwatch weiß ich nicht wahrscheinlich auch das hat auch
ein bisschen problematisch aber gerade auch neue releases du weißt halt nicht wie gut und ob das
gescheit funktioniert heißt wenn du einfach nur in steam gehen willst neues spiel kaufen bei release
los spielen sein linux immer so ja weißt halt nicht aber es geht schon enorm viel und bevor es
losgeht ich bin kein linux super duper checker experte nutze linux seit vielen jahren hin und
wieder auf raspis auf irgendwelchen servern aber ich bin ganz und gar kein desktop linux experte
dafür habe ich glücklicherweise meine kollegin liane die ist wirklich linux expertin das video
ist also aus der perspektive von leuten erzählt die sich nicht so wahnsinnig super auskennen und
es ist aber so ein bisschen so eine mischung aus erfahrungsbericht und auch ein bisschen tutorial
also ihr könnt es auch alles nachmachen und falls ihr euch fragt warum ich ausgleich nicht
jetzt solche lust verspürt habe auf desktop linux zu wechseln ja mehrere sachen einmal weil ich
seit einigen wenn aus elf sagt mit k.i software wie stable diffusion und whisper von open AI
experimentiere und wenn man sich da die anleitung anschaut eins ok eine sache muss ich ja sagen die
hat sich wirklich auch enorm verbessert unter linux die letzten jahre über und das ist das
ganze font rendering und handeln von schriftdaten der linux die letzten jahre über ein bisschen
begleitet hat benutzt hat vielleicht auch als hauptsystem eine weile hatte und wie gesagt ich
rede ich rede hier zeitraum 2005 bis jetzt also ich bin da wirklich schon eine ganze weile dabei
also sind jetzt aber fast fast runden wir mal auf fast 20 jahre nicht ganz und da muss man
halt sagen font rendering war lange zeit ein riesen problem unter linux also die mitgelieferten
schriftdaten waren zum größten teil plattercrap sind sie heute immer noch also knu free fonts
auch auch wenn ihr stolmen mich jetzt anspringen wird wenn er könnte knu free fonts sind absolut
müll genau er den meine ich also vieles was da und auch die die standard fonts fonts von x und so das
ist alles müll und es hat ja ewig gedauert mit font config und den eigentlichen font renderern
bis sie das alles unterstützt haben und so was das hat sich sehr viel getan die letzten jahre aber
es war auch lange zeit wirklich abartig ubuntu hat sehr viel gemacht in der richtung ja genau
nikola hat da wirklich viel gemacht so und da hat sich viel getan guckt euch das mal an ich bin
der fast der meinung dieses set von schriftdaten und das rendering dieser fonts sieht die font
mäßig besser aus als unter windows mac ist vielleicht ähnlich okay aber da hat sich viel
getan anschaut da merkt man schnell dass linux da einfach und ich weiß es ist schwierig zu
erkennen oftmals wenn man das nicht direkt nebeneinander sieht denkt man sich so wo soll
dann der unterschied sein aber es war ein unterschied und gerade ausgefranzte schriftarten
und und solche probleme hattest du früher zu hauf unter linux das ist das ist viel besser
geworden und mittlerweile ist es wirklich gut auch default mäßig die standardplattform ist
du kannst dich hier von trainering technisch kannst du dich überhaupt mehr beschweren das
ist alles top in ordnung sachen laufen windows und mac os geht auch irgendwie aber das wirkt
unterschwellig immer so ein bisschen so wie eine notlösung außerdem hat mir liane glaubhaft
versichert dass dank der proton software fast alle windows spiele unter linux laufen und das von
mir genutzte videoschnittprogramm damit fast fast ist halt wie bei einem internetanschluss bis zu
resolve gibt sogar nativ für linux ob das wirklich funktioniert ja soll angeblich ziemlich gut
funktionieren habe ich auch schon gehört als allerletztes habe ich den subreddit unix
porn ist ein super subreddit da gucke ich auch regelmäßig drinne was ist denn der
unterschied zwischen chromium und chrome chrome ist das was eins zu eins von google kommt
chromium ist quasi den source code genommen von chrome und neu gebaut mit eventuell auch ein
paar deaktivierten features zum beispiel hat mein chromium hat kein wie heißt das ding cast
google cast es ist google chrome chrome cast chrome cast mein chromium hat beispielsweise
kein chrome cast drinne keine dm geschichten und sowas ja okay das stimmt ein paar features
im deaktiviert in meinem chromium deshalb habe ich aber absichtlich dass mich dafür entschieden
weil ich das an der stelle haben wollte letztendlich wenn du einfach nur einen browser haben willst
der geht neben weiterhin chrome kann kein ding so leute ihre heftigst modifizierten linux
das eigentlich leute das leute ich weiß nicht ob ich das auf youtube machen könnte aber ich
könnte zu unix porn reacten da könnten wir regelmäßig mal gucken ich glaube das kann
ich nicht auf youtube bringen es interessiert kein mensch aber wir können uns dem stream ab
und zu mal angucken autotuner art irgendwie vielleicht auch gleich so jetzt stelle ich
natürlich vor dem ersten großen linux problem welche der ungefähr acht millionen distribution
soll ich nehmen ich hätte voll art by the way immer wenn man wenn man nicht weiß was
vernehmen soll ist die antwort immer art ok realistisch betrachtet natürlich nicht weil
art für einsteiger vielleicht nicht das beste ist für einsteiger ist sowas wie mint beispielsweise
ganz nice oder auch ubuntu ja ging ubuntu spricht ich persönlich würde immer mint
empfehlen ich finde mit mit made desktop ganz nice manch einer mit sagen made ist so altbacken
lieber cinnamon was auch immer ich mag ich mag mit noch am ehesten von den klassischen
des tops wenn ich nicht meine 3 verwende
mint ist eine gute sache das schöne an lielungs mint ist dass es eben auch eine große gefolgschaft
hat und viel community drum drum drum drum drum drum drum drum drum drum drum drum drum drum
gibts ein linux für kinder es gab mal so nen so nen education ubuntu falls falls es
dafür sein soll keine ahnung ob es das noch gibt ansonsten ansonsten würde ich sagen das
womit der papa gut klarkommen weil er muss ich ja im endeffekt darum kümmern fällt mir
jetzt so pauschal nix ein längeren mal ne ct-uplink folge gehört wo es genau darum ging dort
wurde auch der echt ziemlich nette von ct konzipierte linux fahrplan erklärt da kann
man so mit dem finger so ne u-bahn abfahren und gucken welche distro an welchen stationen
hält die stationen sind dann aber halt features wenn es mir zum beispiel darum geht immer
auf dem aktuellen software stand zu sein und da kommen halt nur art linux manjaro und open
suzett gen 2 gen 2 einfach alles selber kompilieren iso ich iso easy was kommt in frage jetzt
habe ich gar nicht richtig zu gehört art linux manjaro und open suzett tumbleweed in
frage suzeman alter monka es open suzett kann ja wirklich kann ich mich ja nur nur schütteln
wenn ich das höre die anderen wie ubuntu und fedora bekommen nur zweimal im jahr ein
großes update und der gegensatz davon ist rolling release wie eben zum beispiel bei
art linux da werden die updates einfach immer schreibchenweise eingespielt wenn sie im
fertig wo wir gerade dabei sind sekunde sekunde muss man kurz was gucken wo wir gerade bei
rolling release sind leute wir machen mal kurz den update während das läuft so viel
so viel zum thema rolling release muss man halt öfters mal updaten aber pack man und
das ist für eines der richtig coolen sachen an art linux der mist ist einfach schnell
bis jetzt jetzt ungefähr hätte abt angefangen überhaupt die updates zu installieren so guck
ja bämen auch noch den ganzen kreml hinten drauf neues visual studio gib ihm jawoll
yes hast du schon mal was mit keyclock gemacht ja ich weiß aber ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr
genau was und ich weiß auch nicht mehr was es ist ja habe ich ich weiß wir haben auf
der arbeit in keyclock service gehabt das hat irgendwas mit authentifizierung zu tun
glaube ich aber ich war ja also wir hatten wir sagt der name was ich kann mich da noch
an den namen kann ich mir noch gut erinnern ich weiß aber nicht mehr genau in welchem
kontext wir das verwendet haben und und was wir da gemacht haben keine ahnung mehr genau
es hat irgendwas mit authentifizierung zu tun so machen wir mal ein reboot dann gucken wir
weiter wir haben jetzt nebenbei geupdatet wenn der typ uns schon was von rolling release
erzählt dann machen wir jetzt auch mal abdeckt was hier das ist mein kein fokus oh kein
automatisches login gerade aktiviert ist da los anzeige ok exzellent
weiter ja und art gilt in seiner urform als etwas minimalistisch ich benutze übrigens
auch art nur dass es wisst vor allem spröde zu installieren deshalb habe ich mich für das auf
falls ich es noch nicht erwähnt habe art spazierende aber etwas benutzerfreundlichere endeavour os
gesehen habe dass das auch haben wir das ok sekunde das muss man haben wir das nicht sogar
schon mal ausprobiert ende in der war o.s. hört man das so endeavor o.s. ausprobieren art
spidey fast ein jahr her ich glaube ich fand das ganz gut sogar fand ich das ganz gut
maxi webseite ist kaputt aus irgendwelchen gründen
müssen wir noch mal aus wir können es tatsächlich demnächst noch mal ausprobieren
vorher machen wir aber set servers aus den verstehen geblieben hier viele desktop
environments parallel mit installieren kann und ich die so drei beste wir hatten uns das
glaube ich auch mit die drei angeguckt endeavor ausprobieren kann desktop environments sind
quasi konkret die benutzer oberflächen also wie die icons aussehen die taskleiste aussieht das
machen die desktop environments ja und ich weiß man kann bei vielen linuxen und der fensterrand
wäre mir schon viel zu dick aber wie gesagt ist alles geschmackssache viele desktop environments
installieren aber bei endeavor erschien es mir sehr einfach weil man am anfang halt alles anklicken
kann wahrscheinlich kommen die auch dementsprechend sind ich vorkonfiguriert und linux
ist ja bekanntlich gefühlssache also los geht ihr könnt das natürlich auf einer einzelnen
neuen ssd installieren oder auf einer freien partition ich hatte beides oder deshalb habe
ich mir einfach eine vm schnappen und ausprobieren eine vorhandene windows partition verkleinert in
der datenträgerverwaltung unter windows findet ihr unter computerverwaltung mit rechts auf eine
partition mit freiem platz gehen und dann partition verkleinern wenn ihr dann danach einen bereich mit
nicht zu geordnet habt dann könnt ihr darauf linux installieren aber erst mal gut das geht
mit installations image runterladen unserem fall natürlich für endeavor us damit balena etcher
oder am anderen tool auf dem usb stick und dann entweder im uefi leute ich habe meine frage an
euch wie konnte es eigentlich soweit kommen dass das beste tool zum flaschen eines usb sticks eine
browser basierte javascript anwendung ist warum ist das eigentlich so hat da irgendwie einer
eine logische erklärung dafür wie wir haben wie konnte es soweit kommen
ich benutze das ja auch wenn mich ja gar nicht
ich meine etcher ich bin ich benutze es ja auch teilweise aber
warum muss es nur javascript basierte elektron anwendung sein
die idee ist das beste idee ist vor allem das beste aus versehen irgendwas zu überschreiben
die boot reinfolge so ändern dass der usb stick vor eurem bisherigen systemlaufwerk
auftaucht oder beim booten zum beispiel f12 fürs bootmenü drücken dann kann man
halt temporär mal vom usb stick booten statt vom anderen datenträger wenn es euch möglich
ist solltet ihr secure boot erst mal abschalten secure boot kann man unter linux nutzen aber das
ist richtige arbeit das würde ich mir ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht zutrauen also kein secure
boot für mich so endeavor und die meisten aktuellen linux distries booten erst mal
secure boot brauche ich keine also ihr müsst beim booten einmal auswählen ob ihr erlaubt dass die
nicht open source invidia treiber genutzt werden ich habe das gemacht bei mir weil ich nutze hier
auf dem system der invidia karte so jetzt könnt ihr auf jeden fall alles in ruhe erstmal ausprobieren
ob euch das gefällt und wenn nicht einfach runterfahren und usb stick wieder rausnehmen
und auf eurem system hat sich kein einziges bit verändert erst wenn ihr das linux aus dem live
modus heraus fest installiert das geht bei endeavor mit dem programm welcome ja dann
ist es halt richtig installiert dafür klickt ihr dann hier bei der auswahl das ist ja tatsächlich
bei vielen distributionen so dass du die erst mal live startest bisschen rum umklicken kannst
und dann startest den installer ja bei ubuntu auch so gut ich glaube du kannst bei ubuntu den installer
auch direkt direkt starten weiß ich weiß nicht ob man unter ubuntu noch den text konsolen installer
überhaupt dabei hat also früher habe ich am liebsten ubuntu einfach mit dem text installer
installiert aber ok weiß ich ob es das noch gibt der neue text installer ist ja auch irgendwie
komisch der ist so komischen cli gui framework wo ich nicht so richtig mit klarkomme aber gut
ich habe ehrlich gesagt wenn aus nicht wenn aus ubuntu sehr selten in letzter zeit händisch
installiert das weiße kommt von irgendwelchen cloud vms und das sind fertige images
position auf einen leeren datenträger oder auf den vorher freigemachten und
welche erfahrung habt ihr mit amd grafikkarten unter linux also ich kann das nur vom hören sagen
berichten weil ich linux bei mir auf dem rechner nichts direkt in selet haben sollten in der vm also
gut ich meine ich kann es dir sagen die intel sachen onboard funktionen wunderbar das habe ich
nämlich jahrelang auf der arbeit auf notebook verwendet und aktuell auch wieder auf den
nordpunkt ist es kein problem hören sagen ist dass intel zur zeit tatsächlich endlich intel das
amd zurzeit tatsächlich besser support ist beziehungsweise besser bei modernen karten
funktioniert unter linux als nvidia früher war das umgedreht da liefen amd sachen gar nicht
richtig dabei da hatte nvidia auch als einziges vor den proprietären nvidia treiber mit dem
man viel mehr ging als mit dem mit dem open source treiber wie es jetzt ist kann ich euch nicht aus
erster hand berichten vom hören sagen hier ist amd ziemlich gut und intel und intel weiß ich aus
erster hand intel funktioniert eigentlich immer reich und aber intel ist ja bei einer linux
entwicklung generell immer gut dabei andere ist glaube linux hatte unterstützung für die
neuen cpus also die die 13.900 k zb mit efficiency course ich glaube linux hatte
unterstützung noch vor windows nämlich selbsterklärend ihr werdet zum beispiel gefragt welche desktop
umgebung ihr haben wollt da gibt es etliche xfc leute xfc hat das beste maskottchen xfc
leute maskottchen nein den da meine ich die maus beste also wenn ich chico fragen könnte
was die beste desktop umgebung ist dann würde chico wahrscheinlich sagen das da
und halt mehrere installieren und dann nachher on the fly umschalten der einzige nachteil davon
ist dass ihr dann einige zu den desktop umgebungen gehörenden tools nebeneinander installiert habt
das heißt ihr seht dann beispielsweise unter gnome eigentlich zu kde plasma gehörende
programme finde ich vielleicht sogar gar nicht schlecht weil die laufen auch auf anderen
desktop umgebungen ja aber bei meinem ersten installationsversuch hatte ich ansonsten alles
auf standard gelassen und dann nutzt endeavor zum beispiel den boot manager system die boot und
den hat mein rechner beziehungsweise mein uefi irgendwie nicht gefunden ich konnte hier im
bootmenü immer nur windows booten und im uefi menü konnte ich auch nichts umschalten das hat
jetzt nix kaputt gemacht auf meinem system aber ich bin halt nicht in linux reingekommen ich
habe deshalb die installation noch mal neu gemacht aber diesmal grub statt systemd ausgewählt man
hätte wahrscheinlich auch die uefi einträge neu erzeugen können aber ist natürlich doof wenn
das wenn es nicht geht ist komplexer größer und älter als system die ja das hat bei mir
besser funktioniert da konnte ich dann kann aber auch mehr heißt das jetzt zwischen windows und
linux umschalten eigentlich sollten die linux boot manager windows partition erkennen und die
ins auswahlmenü einhängen aber das muss nicht funktionieren wie ich ja nun feststellen muss
also das solltet ihr definitiv bedenken wenn ihr linux auf einem system installieren wollt
und noch andere betriebssysteme drauf sind im zweifel müsst ihr danach etwas troubleshooting
im schlimmsten fall kommt ihr dann erstmal nicht an alle installen wie ist das eigentlich mal
angenommen man macht jetzt dual boot ich habe eine weile kein dual boot mehr gemacht angenommen
man macht jetzt dual boot windows seit windows 10 hat ja die angewohnheit dass bei manchen feature
updates es unter der haube eine komplette neuinstallation ist dann installiert er doch
bestimmt auch den bootloader neu und dementsprechend kommt ihr nicht mehr in linux rein oder würde ich
jetzt mal vermuten überschreibt dann überschreibt dann einfach den grab und macht sein windows ding
hin keine probleme vielleicht erkennt ja windows mittlerweile auch so was ich mein windows ist
war immer recht rücksichtslos was andere systeme angeht hat windows zugriff auf grab klar warum nicht
installierten betriebssysteme dran bei mir kann ich jetzt zumindest im uefi umschalten ob ich in
windows oder linux reinbooten will das ist nicht super elegant und das werde ich wahrscheinlich
langfristig auch noch versuchen zu reparieren aber es ist erstmal ok jedenfalls installiert
ist jetzt alles und ich muss echt erstmal feststellen alles funktioniert out of the box
mein 4k monitor hat die richtige auflösung die webcam funktioniert die frage ist nicht so sehr
ob sie richtige auflösung hat sondern ob dpi scaling und solche sachen ordentlich funktionieren
ob sub pixel rendering für fonts und so richtig funktioniert da höre ich immer wieder so was ich
höre ich höre nicht sehe das öfters auf reddit und lesen das auf reddit zum beispiel dass es mit
4k monitoren noch die ein oder anderen probleme gibt also wie gesagt gerade was skalierung angeht
so sub pixel rendering und sowas dass da manchmal probleme gibt aber bei gut bei ihm wahrscheinlich
die externe festplatte wird mir hier im datei manager angezeigt ich muss übrigens mal sagen ich
finde dieses video in extrem gut und angenehm geschnitten und gemacht das ist nicht so mega
krass hyperaktives zoomer youtube aber das ist genau richtig dass es dir nicht langweilig wird
finde ich gut datesystem ntfs läuft apropos microsoft wusstet ihr dass es den windows browser
edge für linux ja wusste ich wirklich gelacht wusste ich ich habe keine ahnung was die
existenzberechtigung ist ich kenne auch niemand haben noch niemand gesehen der ihn verwendet aber
ja das gibt es gesehen weil edge ist ja schon unter windows ich sag mal eher unbeliebt und das
nun auf linux zu installieren das fühlt sich richtig rebellisch an mit dem klassenfeind und
von den desktop umgebungen kann man amazon prime in 4k schauen was ist da wie meinst du das also
wo kann man amazon prime in 4k schauen unter linux oder was meinst du ach wegen dem dm ich also ich
weiß es nicht weil ich das unter linux nicht ausprobiert habe ich vermute mal in chrome dürfte
das unter linux kein problem sein oder doch oder nicht also warum warum sollte es ein problem sein
hardware acceleration das ist tatsächlich ein problem das ist halt auch so diese typische
linux geschichte wo sie sich lieber sechs jahre lang streiten wer jetzt dafür verantwortlich ist
warum es nicht richtig geht wahrscheinlich sogar mehrere die köln entwickler das die
windowsystem hersteller die mesa treiber dinger das windowsystem der grafikkarten hersteller
der treiber programmierer und dann geht am ende halt keine hardware gpu decoding für videos was
doof ist gerade auf notebooks weil das viel mehr strom zieht videos über die cpu zu decoden also
über die grafikkarten ich meine wir reden hier von zwei bis drei prozent cpu last und ein bisschen
grafikkarte versus 70 prozent cpu last teilweise und selbst heutzutage geht es auch nur in der
passenden kombination aus browserversion mesa treiber dann hast du nicht gesehen und selbst
dann noch nicht alle codecs ja du hast dann so sachen wie zum beispiel hat 265 funktioniert
unter windows schon lange ohne probleme hardware decoded unter linux nicht richtig oder vp9 und
solche geschichten das einzige was meistens ganz gut funktioniert ist hat 264 was aber auch der
wichtigste codec ist noem am hübschsten so sieht das bei mir aus mit der windows tast oder auch
neutraler option ist kann man einfach immer das menü aufpoppen lassen und dann auch per
tastatur suchbegriffe eingeben ich finde das klappt super smooth und da habe ich mich sofort dran
gewöhnt was mich allerdings stark irritiert hat dass im terminal copy paste nicht mit steuerung c
und v steuerung schiff c und v das irritiert wahrscheinlich so gut wie alle umsteiger und
der meck hast du das problem anderweitig gelöst die haben eine extra taste für so was aber steuerung
c ist halt im terminal anderweitig historisch belegt da hat sie auch hier oben stehen steuerung c
ist ein terminal befehle programme zu abzubrechen zu beenden genau man sollte es auf gar keinen fall
ändern oder ihr macht das so wie ich das gemacht habe in meinem terminal guckt mal wie gut das
funktioniert ich kann das mit der maus machen schaut mal das ist ich finde das ist wirklich
eine gute lösung also wenn ich was wenn ich was markiere sagen wir jetzt mal hier punkt wie es
code habe ich markiert wenn ich jetzt die rechte maus taste drücke hier rechte maus taste dann
ist das in der zwischen ablage kann ich euch beweisen hier mein clipboard manager ist in
der zwischen ablage und wenn ich jetzt noch mal die rechte maus taste drücke dann pastet er also
sprich wenn ich was kopieren will und pasten kann ich es einfach anklicken rechte maus
taste rechte maus taste und zum einfügen alternativ kann ich auch die mittlere maus
taste drücken warum nicht alles markierte automatisch ganz einfach du möchtest ja
vielleicht hier markieren allerdings nicht hier sondern hier einfügen das ist nicht die
standardeinstellung mit der rechten maus taste das habe ich selbst in meiner terminal konfig
rein rein gebastelt das terminal das ist westerm so sieht die konfig dafür aus ja das das ist die
konfig dafür dass das funktioniert ne ne das hier das ist die konfig dafür dass das funktioniert
also der guckt ist was selected wenn etwas selected ist dann pastet er es ins clipboard und
clear die selection und wenn nichts selected ist pastet er das ist zumindest hier nicht die
defaulteinstellung wie schließt du pains in westerm in dem ich die shell beende drück
einfach steuerung d steuerung t d ist quasi das gleiche wie exit oder unter windows ist
glaube ich quitt also exit steuerung d einfach steuerung d es ist besser die shell zu beenden
als das tab abzuschießen du kannst das tab auch abschießen aber wenn du den shell lockout benutzt
und sagen zum beispiel sowas hier du hast jetzt wim offen machst in den hintergrund du willst
dich hier auslocken dann sagt er geht nicht weil du noch weil du noch jobs im hintergrund
hast ich meine wenn du es dann forst geht es auch geht es auch weg sind die jobs natürlich
natürlich sprich wenn du was offen hast hast den hintergrund gescheckt und möchtest dich
auslocken dann sagt er aber wenn du hast du hast background jobs die kannst du erstmal
beenden und nicht auslocken ja finde ich sehr praktisch das ist westerm nennt sich das ganze
hier westerm haben wir haben wir zusammen im stream entdeckt ein super terminal gibt es auch
für windows und für mac glaube ich werde es in zukunft auch in der windows verwenden
ist ein super ding hat gpu accelerated rendering für den text als transparenz wie man hier im
hintergrund sieht hat eine konfigurations datei die man entweder ganz klassisch verwenden kann
sowas wie hier winnow background und uns scroll back lines aber auch die möglichkeit über lua
die konfig zu extenden also es ist super sache also westerm hat mich überzeugt das beste
terminal was ich die letzten jahre über gefunden habe ja kitty kitty habe ich so ein paar probleme
mit weil ich ja meine sachen nicht rein lokal verwende ich meine ich administriere professionell
klingt jetzt wichtig ja aber ich verdiene mein geld damit unter anderem regelmäßig mich auf
linux systeme einzuloggen und dort auch teamwork sessions zu haben solche geschichten und ssh und
t-marks und das alles in kombination ist bei kitty etwas problematisch was auch daran liegt
dass der kitty autor überhaupt kein bock drauf hat das zu supporten saurei
da kann man kann ich sagen dass besser ist es ist anders es hat mehr features zum beispiel zum
beispiel kannst du panels oder kannst du pains splitten und aufmachen wie in t-marks nur dass
es native im terminal ist also das ist es es sieht aus wie eine t-marks session ist es nicht dass
es native im terminal hier was sie auch schon an den hintergrundänderungen sieht und sowas
ja also du hast tapp support du hast tapp support kann es auch multiplexen ja kann es also die
einfachste variante ist das hier mit mit pens und du kannst glaube ich garantiert irgendwie auch
einstellen dass du in allen terminals das gleiche schreibst du hast auch die möglichkeit das
irgendwie im hintergrund laufen zu lassen dass es nicht abkackt da gibt es verschiedene
varianten habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert das ist das ist nice
jep ok wir gucken das video weiter
überall außerhalb des terminals geht es wieder ohne schiff ich weiß ich weiß man kann sich das
natürlich anders konfigurieren will man aber nicht konnte control c sollte man nicht um
belegen habe ich bis dahin noch nicht gemacht und muss ich auch sagen habe ich nicht ganz
verstanden warum das jetzt unbedingt so anders sein was vielleicht wissen ja das muss so sein
weil control c schon belegt ist und mit was recht wichtigem nämlich programme abbrechen die laufen
das braucht man am laufenden band im terminal ihr den grund wenn man noch radikaler sein will
als edge zu installieren kann man sich sogar die von windows bekannte powershell ja kann man auch
installieren die gibt es wirklich also bei einem betriebssystem was ja nun wirklich vor allem für
seine extrem leistungsstarken shells bekannt ist da nun die windows schild ist doch schön
geht ich mein ich habe jetzt ja keinen bock drauf das zu verwenden ja aber wie kommt man
denn überhaupt menschen ich muss sagen western finde ich tatsächlich konkurrenzfähig dazu und
weißt du dass die sogar sich ein paar sachen aus item abgeguckt haben zum beispiel muss ich
jetzt auch hier an der stelle noch mal zeigen zum beispiel ich habe hier einen ordner mit bildern
ja und wir machen jetzt mal so was image ket punkt kann sogar bilder im terminal anzeigen lassen also
high res bilder nicht dieses ascii in ascii umgewandt von früher und das haben die von
iterm ich will nicht sagen geklaut weil das ja absichtlich so gemacht ist dass es auch andere
terminals implementieren können die haben das iterm image protokoll implementiert du kannst jetzt
auch bilder nicht nur bilder sogar gif animationen kannst du im terminal anzeigen lassen das schon
nice dass das hier dass das hier in zwei spalten ist und resize und so was da habe ich ein bisschen
script drumherum gebaut das ist nicht von denen normalerweise müsste man machen west term image
ket genau sowas müsste man hier machen vielleicht ist noch das richtige hier angeben in dem ordner
ich habe da so ein kleines rapper rapper script drumherum gebastelt was es mir erlaubt das in
zwei spalten anzuzeigen und mit dem dateinamen oben drüber und bei the way auch svgs anzeigen
kann was das normale nicht kann guck das kann svg anzeigen das kann kein svg anzeigen weiter
die grunde chat auch skalierbar du meinst dass wenn ich das terminal resize oder oder was
ach die es na gut wenn ich das terminal resize passiert natürlich nix wenn ich die wenn ich das
terminal wenn ich die schrift kleiner mache und es noch mal ausführe dann ist das bild größer
ne pdf nicht aber pdf könnte man pdf könnte man leute sekunde das muss ich mal kurz ausbrechen
kann ffm pack pdf mein ffm pack kann kann nahezu alles kann ich brauche hat man schön example pdf
sekunde leute das muss man ganz kurz ausprobieren dummy pdf sehr gut das brauche ich damit pdf
sekunde das testen wir jetzt mal kurz wegen damit pdf ffm pack ich habe noch nie versucht mit
ffm pack den pdf aufzumachen mann null punkt png ah ne ok das wäre es jetzt auch mann ffm pack
mit pdf aber es gibt garantiert pdf to image dinger für linux dann könnte man das machen ja
also linux pdf to image zu png zum beispiel weiß ich nicht wie man das macht was ist da so was
es da so gibt gimp pdf to pdf wie heißt das ding pdf to ppm
hier gibt es image magic kann das das stimmt pdf to png wie geht das image magic jawoll
gimp convert density alles klar x wie habe ich nicht habe ich nicht installiert image magic mein
beste so guck so damit dummy pdf resize ok weil ich habe ich go script nicht jetzt ok ist scheiß drauf
image magic was meint ihr pandoc kann das bestimmt können wir ausprobieren
ach panno ist dieses haskell ding so hier cli hat immer what the ffm pack
das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu übertrieben ups was soll ich erzählen poplar poplar poplar
pdf rendering library based on x pdf ok pocket das brauchen wir pdf to pdf to kairo what to ppm ok
alles klar also dummy wie wissen da die wissen da die sonntags für pdf fallen ok ok also sprich
dummy pdf nach dummy punkt png ne geht das jetzt image cat dummy punkt png ane hier png ppm get easy
schon haben wir schon haben wir den kram auf der auf der kommande zeile natürlich ist es keine
allzu schöne variante das so zu machen weil da braucht man immer eine temporäre datei also was
man was man jetzt natürlich machen könnte ist ich war schon mal schauen ob das ob das funktioniert
ob man das peipen kann also man jetzt zum beispiel ffm pack minus i und dann blub punkt png macht
ok
das funktioniert
das würde funktionieren also man kann dummy man kann das man kann das danach ffm pack
peipen und dann um dann da raus in png zu machen das würde das würde klappen
das würde klappen so da muss man das natürlich ein bisschen bisschen größer
skalieren weil das jetzt alles ein bisschen klein ist
ne wie habe wie habe ich genannt blub punkt png dummy pdf fall also jop
wir können wir können es auch auf dem terminal pdf rennen
wenn man sich jetzt mal die richtigen optionen wenn man sich jetzt mal die richtigen optionen
aus was passiert bei mehreren ok dummy pdf haben wir haben wir habt ihr hat ihr mal ein gutes
gutes keine ahnung pdf pysons spec irgendwie sowas
pdf ok die pysen dokumentation pdf alles klar 13 mb ok das jetzt zu übertrieben
ne computer science 1 ok perfekt das ist ja das sind ja nur das sind ja nur 613 seiten
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert wie gert
ok also nur nur 2,2 mb ok gucken wir mal jetzt bin ich gespannt ob das
ob das funktioniert man ok computer science pdf blub pfm pack möchte da draus mehrere bilder
machen alles klar guck jetzt hast du bloß jetzt hast du bloß das das das blatt ok
ffm pack macht quasi ein png pro seite da draus
gut das also das leute das könnte man garantiert ordentlich verskripten dass
es dann seitenweise auf der auf der kommando zeile rauskommt
also man könnte garantiert jetzt an der stelle sagen ok das probieren wir noch mal ganz schnell
aus da war weiter könnte garantiert an der stelle sagen
das skalieren wir das mal png sondern hauen wir das wieder auf dem standard standard auch
raus na gif gif gif es ist blödsinn aber wir können wahrscheinlich jetzt sagen input das
standard output wieder drauf raushauen und jetzt das ganze palpen und entweder ich wir
habe ich hier gemacht nach western image kett ok alles klar und jetzt das ganze palpen nach
western image kett ok es rendert die frage ist nur gleich ist fertig 610 sein das zeigt
nur das erste an das zeigt nur das erste an an der stelle das wüsste man also irgendwie
verskripten das wüsste man irgendwie verskripten könnte man auf jeden fall machen baue ich
vielleicht sogar ein es ist eine gute idee damit auch pdf auf dem auf dem terminal anzeigbar
zu machen man muss halt man muss halt ein bisschen trigg 17 trigg 17 machen
wie oft braucht man das das ist nicht der punkt es ist nicht die frage wie oft man das
braucht die frage ist ob es geht und es braucht wenn es darum geht braucht wahrscheinlich das
wenigste du brauchst was zu essen du brauchst was zu trinken du brauchst was zu schlafen du
brauchst ein klo zum kacken das war es dann aber ok vielleicht noch was zum atmen was zum
atmen ist auch nicht schlecht also das könnte man auf jeden fall ordentlich ordentlich skripten
ist natürlich die frage ob man ffm pack überhaupt rauch
oder ob das nicht vielleicht so sogar funktioniert ok was passiert jetzt
ich bin mir unschlüssig was what is happening
oh fuck
irgendwie ist mein terminal dead ok ich glaube ich habe ich habe schnell genug
noch abgebrochen das war keine so gute idee les les kann doch nicht anzeigen binary blub
blub blub ok das das funktioniert schon mal nicht die weg les kann ich funktionen
das teuch braucht einfach nur krass viele ram kann es sein ok ein cpu kern ist komplett
du hast pdf to text ok ja das stimmt das funktioniert das funktioniert ok jetzt
haben wir hier null punkt png oh shit der hat jetzt jede seite der hat jetzt jede seite in
meinen wie groß ist der ordner jetzt aber das wind aus iso aber das ist trotzdem das
ist trotzdem ganz schön groß null vier gigabyte ok rm lull lull störnchen ja ja ok passt
auch noch mal kluge habt ihr also ist wahrscheinlich ist wahrscheinlich die variante die ich hier
gemacht habe mit peipen nach ffm pack gar nicht mal so doof gut werde ich mir werde ich mir
anderweitig anderweitig mal angucken wir gucken jetzt wir gucken jetzt das video fertig
jetzt ein software und falls ihr abt beziehungsweise ab gett von dibian linuxen gewöhnt
seid müsst ihr euch bei art linuxen pack man beste pack man der stand oder oder noch besser
ein art user repo helper tool und paketmanager pack kennste den typ kenne ich ja
zeit mal was was passiert da
ich weiß nicht was das ist aber der hat gerade sein heimatverzeichnis gelöscht
r-f da hat gerade sein heimatverzeichnis gelöscht ja kommt vor ja das kann passieren deswegen
für leute die nicht wollen dass einem sowas passiert einfach mal ein blick in meine dort
falls werfen und dort ein blick in meine zshrc werfen und da wird man feststellen da steht
sowas hier drinnen guckt mal function rm aliast weile ich wirklich aliast sondern umgebogen auf
rm-i der grund warum ich das so gemacht habe ist folgender wenn du also bei rm ist es so
der zuletzt angegebene parameter zählt das heißt wenn ich rm mache also zum beispiel
bin rm blub punkt png wenn ich jetzt sage dass da rm minus f das ist schon eine komische
kombination ja also eine gefährliche kombination und da vor ein minus i mache dann löscht er
das einfach bm touch blub punkt png wenn ich das minus i wobei jetzt ein unterschied zwischen
groß und klein i gibt wenn ich das dahinter mache dann fragt er mich warum weil das minus
i in dem fall das letzte argument ist und deswegen gilt also wenn ich inte ist für
interaktiv also wenn ich interaktiv hinten stehen habe dann fragt er mich und wenn ich
interaktiv vorne stehen habe überschreibt das force das interaktiv deswegen habe ich in meine
shell konfig reingeschrieben rm wird aliast auf rm hier an der stelle werden alle weitere
parameter eingefügt die es so gibt und am ende ein minus i ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das nicht
irgendwelche seitendeffekte hat mit denen ich noch nicht gerechnet habe das will ich nicht
ausschließen aber bis jetzt hat sich das ganz gut bewährt ist das nicht debian default in der in
der form nicht so und das heißt ich überschreibe mit einem interaktiv am ende immer diese sachen
wie wie force das aber die sache ist jetzt ja die überlegt euch mal wir machen jetzt tatsächlich
was den fall belegt euch mal ich habe hier einen ordner blub so und in diesem ordner legen wir jetzt
mal 1000 dateien an was haben wir hier auf einmal 1000 dateien drinne wenn ich jetzt sage m minus
i löschen dann fragt er mich dann dann fragt er mich zu viel zu viel nerviges zu viel nerviges
zeug im zweifelsfall je nach dem videos macht fragt er dich auch bei jeder einzelnen datei deswegen
deswegen gibt es minus groß i und minus groß i ist eigentlich ganz gut weil minus klein i fragt
dich bei jeder datei minus groß i sorgt dafür dass es dich nur einmal fragt und dann auch nur
wenn es mehr als drei dateien entfernt
oder wenn du ein ein verzeichnis löscht das ist eigentlich ganz ganz praktisch
also groß ist ziemlich prog
also ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es sich irgendwelche seiten blöden seiteneffekte
hat aber bis jetzt finde ich das hier gar nicht so verkehrt
mal schauen ob sich das etabliert müssen wir mal gucken
rm auf trash cli legen ne das mag ich nicht das hatte ich ganz lange habe ich in der
alten vm auch noch das hat mir aber zunehmend weniger gefallen
so video fertig gucken sonst man das heute noch irgendwann schaffen
also das ding funktioniert eigentlich genau wie ab also es installiert und
gibt es einen seriösen wie emulator bei dem man nicht mega viel konfigurieren muss
keine ahnung ich habe keinen wie emulator bisher konfigurieren ich habe das package
unter barthos era installiert und es ging
das package musste gar nicht ins den das die spiele drauf kopiert das war ja schon
alles dabei und dann ging es bist du nicht moment sekunde leute das ist
natürlich eine gute frage aber
wie wird das entschieden es wird immer die funktion genommen weil ich das
eben weil das das letzte ist was definiert wurde so aber aber kann das
nicht gefährlich werden wenn du zum beispiel auf dem server bist der das
nicht hat weil du es halt anders gewöhnt bist ich bin ja so jetzt auch schon rm
minus rf gewöhnt also das ist jetzt genauso gefährlich wie vorher nur dass
ich bei mir lokal jetzt nicht mehr aus verstehen was löschen kann muss aber
sagen dass bei vielen distributionen in der root in der root bashe rc ähnliche
schutzmaßnahmen drin sind nicht exakt die aber zum beispiel dass du
löschen kannst und sowas weil ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen dass das
mittlerweile sogar bei der das ist mittlerweile sogar die fault ist bei rm
dass du nicht löschen kannst aus sehen aber du kannst ohne problem aus
versehen ein heimatverzeichnis löschen deswegen finde ich das die beste
kombination es frage dich bei mehr als drei dateien oder wenn du rekursiv was
benutzen willst und dann kannst du noch mal draufgucken sagst ja passt will ich
löschen
gibt keine seiten wo man sich nie so geben wie man sich isos ziehen kann doch
aber das welt wird dir hier keiner verraten wo man isos laden kann von
games
du wirst auch selbst was finden setrick mein so schwer ist es ja nur wirklich
nett sich im internet mal auf besuchmaschinen umzugucken und seiten zu
finden wo das angeboten wird was man sucht was es auch immer sein mag
wirst du die spiele von cd auf den rechner bekommen das geht tatsächlich
je nach emulator unterschiedlich aber bei barthus sehr im wiki gibt es unter
anderem für xbox und xbox 360 gibt es anleitungen wie das funktionieren
ja
es gibt ein paar es gibt ein paar sachen die man machen kann mit dateien
haben die ein bisschen dreckreich sind
aber das beste was man lernen kann ist einfach gar nicht von hand eintippen
sondern autocomplete nutzen weil autocomplete macht es in der regel
richtig
so jetzt gucken wir mal echt wird das video fertig aus hinterlegten paketquellen
aber pack man hat leider eine etwas weniger intuitive bedienung finde ich
wollte etwas installieren gibt ich mag ich mag die pack man bedienung und vor
allem mag ich die helfer also die wie nennt sich das wie nennt sich das
eigentlich als ein art user repo helfer die dinger finde ich zum beispiel viel
angenehmer als abt oder jam oder dnf oder sowas
ansonsten ja pack man ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig allerdings
seriously muss es auch nicht viel anders als abt oder oder jam würde bei der bei
der tilde datei nicht auch minus minus funktionieren
wahrscheinlich nicht weil minus minus ja nur sagt dass ab dem zeitpunkt die
parameter keine parameter mehr kommen und alles als argumente gilt das würde
nicht funktionieren also glaube nicht dass es funktionieren würde an der
stelle
bin ich mir jetzt aber nicht ganz sicher was auf jeden fall funktionieren ist
autocomplete verwenden beziehungsweise ein quota vorzumachen und dann
autocomplete zu triggern
wie heißt er noch mal diese gui von manjaro es gibt nicht diese gui von
manjaro
ich frag was
wie ist der umstieg auf zsh zsh ich schreibe gerne best kript und wollte
mal horchen ob es da was zu machen gibt für deine skripte macht das überhaupt
keinen unterschied ich mache übrigens zum größten teil immer noch bin besch
oder bin sh oben hin das für deine skripte macht überhaupt
keinen unterschied die laufen dort exakt so
wie vorher weil sie weiterhin mit besch laufen
ab install ein sondern ihr müsst sudo pacman minus großes s und dann der
programm ist halt gewöhnungsbedürftig steht für sync also synchronisieren also
updaten oder installieren und das sudo schreibt ihr bei linux immer vor
befehle die root zugriff also vollen system zugriff brauchen wollt ihr
um es das ganze system aktualisieren gebt ihr ein sudo pacman minus großes s
minus y minus u genau wenn pacman meldet dass es ein programm nicht findet habt
ihr ganz viele andere möglichkeiten software zu installieren pacman
unterstützt wirklich nur die hochoffiziellen von den entwicklern
zugelassenen programme andere software könnt ihr zum beispiel mit j y a y
beste oder oder wie die coolen leute die quasi nicht verwenden sondern wie ist
das andere written in rust und blazingly fast und weil rust gleich besser paru
paru genau genau
wofür das wofür das y und u steht ich leider ich glaube das eine ist upgrade
und das andere ist package packages also neuen stand von paketquellen
abrufen glaube ich aus dem kopf weiß ich nicht genau
das zappen aber es gibt es gibt ich zeige euch jetzt mal was die frage war
ja gerade was bedeutet das da es gibt eine schöne seite guckt mal
explain ich hoffe die ist jetzt dabei explain schell.com da gehst du drauf und
gibst das ein und sagst explain oder kann es kein pacman
alter keine pacman parameter was ist denn hier los
ja da war er
kennt sich jemand mit maria db aus ja wir haben die richtig krassen datenbank
profis am start gestern einen gehabt mit vier terabyte postgres datenbank wo
nichts mehr ging
der bauer ich dachte das ist ein youtuber der gerne mini pc in flüssigen
stückstoff legt und sowas
ok ich gebe zu der wird zwar schlecht
auch an also dass art user repository das sind von benutzerinnen und benutzern
angelegte installationskripte und die sind weniger offiziell aber man findet
deutlich mehr software auf diese weise aber ganz kurz eine warne findest fast
alles sind halt user skripte also damit kann man sich im schlimmsten fall das
system vergurken bei ein paar paketen macht das nix aber irgendwann hat man
womöglich pech also bitte bedenken. yay benutzt die gleichen parameter wie
pacman also mit yay minus großes s programmname installiert man zeug
außerdem kann man auch noch flatpak oder snap verwenden das sind anwendungscontainer
wo alles benötigt ist
wenn steckt und die software da dann auf wunsch abgeschottet vom restsystem
läuft ob jetzt native installation oder solche container besser sind darüber
wird in linux kreisen hart diskutiert wenn ihr dazu starke meinungen habt
könnt ihr die gerne in die kommentare schreiben für mich immer ganz
interessant wieder so das meinungsbild ist ich habe dazu mal meine kollegin
liane gefragt liane warum ist das alles so verwirrend mit den ganzen
installationsmöglichkeiten warum kann man das nicht standardisieren
so kompliziert ist das doch eigentlich nicht ich habe eine richtige software in
meine pakete ich meine es gibt es gibt ja mittlerweile sogar meta package
manager dass du die nur noch ein package manager merken muss aber ich finde das
ist eigentlich überflüssig da wurde getestet ob die auch zusammenpassen die
kann ich mit einem mit einer software installieren und habe keine probleme und
flatpak ist dazu eine super ergänzung weil da laufen alle programme in so einer
kleinen sandbox und können keinen schaden anrichten und haben keine
eigenen abhängigkeiten die nicht aufgelöst wichtig dass es eine kleine
sandbox ist wüsst werden oder irgend sowas und wenn da wirklich mal was
fehlt kann ich immer noch auf j zurückgreifen das holt sich anhand der
paket beschreibungen im aur die software im zweifel direkt von github also den
quellcode und kompiliert den für mich und alles mit nur einem befehl also was
mich wirklich ganz kurz aus der bahn geworfen hat also wirklich positiv
überrascht hat wie unfassbar simpel es ist windows spiele zum laufen zu kriegen
nämlich einfach indem man über eine der gerade erwähnten möglichkeiten steam
installiert also zum beispiel pack man minus s team einloggen auf einstellung
gehen dann steam play dann bei erweitert die play für alle anderen titel
aktivieren zack fertig läuft ich habe etliche spiele ausprobiert und alle
gingen und das sogar echt gut vor allem die sachen die mit der grafik
schrittstelle vulkan laufe
ist das das dead space remake was er spielt
auf der einen seite sieht es ein bisschen aus wie dead space aber auf der
anderen seite sieht es wieder nicht aus wie dead space
wegen dem gang ach nee genau das ist das ist du
das stimmt schon und dead space ist third person ja mit f
ja ja vergessts offen wie die du null neu auflagen ich muss dann noch mal ein
bisschen wissenschaftlichere tests machen aber ich halte es durchaus
möglich dass die unter linux auf einigen system eine höhere frame rate
erreichen können als unter windows wenn euch das interessiert wir da also mal
mehr zeit und aufwand reinstecken sollen in gaming unter linux dann bitte in die
kommentare schreiben was ich auf jeden fall mit sicherheit sagen kann hotline
miami habe ich unter windows nicht in 4k sind hier in viedertreiber eigentlich
immer noch kacke unter linux also nach alledem was ich so lese ja praktische
erfahrung habe ich damit selber nicht auf bekommen aber na ist es na ist das
soundtrack leute mega na ist das soundtrack sekunde das müssen wir uns
jetzt mal kurz kurz geben fesse cat jam
mit den itty-bitty
ok guck mal das video weiter ist mir nur eingefallen als ich das game gesehen
habe das bild immer so abgeschnitten und unter linux hat es auf anip
funktioniert auf dem gleichen rechner krass oder also zumindest in meinem kopf
ist das thema gaming unter linux nicht mal eingestuft unter ja kann man als
kompromisse den windows kram irgendwie so ein bisschen emulieren sondern als
funktioniert mindestens genauso gut wie unter windows vor allem durch den
erfolg des team decks achten natürlich alle entwicklung studios stark drauf
dass die sachen unter linux funktionieren also das wird in zukunft
das ist tatsächlich wirklich muss man muss man wer öfter auch hoch anrechnen
die machen das natürlich nicht aus reiner nix liebe sondern es gab ja da
auch mal so ein talk von gaben persönlich drüber dass die halt
bisschen abgefuckt sind von microsoft
also wie gesagt sie machen das nicht aus reiner nix liebe aber das haben wir den
fast im allein gang zu verdanken
ja vieles war es nicht funktioniert alles mit das meiste mit anti cheat
kannst du fortnite kannst vergessen rainbow six kannst vergessen und so was
ja wie es bei offer watch aussieht keine ahnung
ja das lieben deck läuft natürlich auch unter linux auch übrigens mit einer
art linux geschmacksrichtung eine einzige gaming kuriosität habe ich aber
zu berichten elden ring lief zuerst bei mir gar nicht da brach der start immer
ab und irgendwo hatte ich gelesen dass man versuchen kann steam als flatpak zu
installieren das habe ich dann gemacht und dann hat elden ring tatsächlich auf anhieb
funktioniert also ein bisschen frickel ist immer noch da vinci resolve hat
mich richtig enttäuscht die kostenlose version hat kein einziges video von mir
lesen können weil da einfach grundlegende codecs fehlen ich habe auch
die kostenpflichtige studio version die hat unter linux etwas bessere codec
unterstützung kann aber zum beispiel kein hard 264 schreiben und beherrscht
den sehr populären aus keiner 264 ich meine ok solange man es nach ffm pack
palmen kann es ist kein problem aber audio codec aac gar nicht also ich kann
es nicht mal lesen mal schauen ob das in zukunft irgendwie gelöst wird weil so
ist das ziemlich unbenutzbar ansonsten hatte ich wenig probleme es hat alles
funktioniert was ich brauchte also auch so spezialitäten wie wire grad also
wirklich ganz ehrlich ich werde definitiv erst mal weiter linux nutzen
als ich mal kurz wieder in windows war neulich hat mich das total genervt zum
beispiel dass man neue updates man startet zum beispiel dann will ständig
ein update installieren da ist win get auch keine große
erleichterung so wirklich ja also win get ist eine coole sache aber unter der
haube sind es halt immer noch unabhängig voneinander paketierte
programme und das macht es vielleicht ein bisschen
einfacher aber insgesamt ist es bei weitem nicht
dort wo ein ordentlicher package manager unter linux ist und klick hier klick da
neu starten und bei linux wird einfach die komplette software auf dem rechner
mit einem befehl aktualisiert ohne rumgeklick ja mir gefällt auch gut dass
ich ganz automatisch beim benutzen immer mehr über linux lerne und weil ich das
ist tatsächlich ein großer vorteil wenn man bock hat sich damit zu
beschäftigen ist es eine super
super plan linux täglich auch zu benutzen und zwar auch auf dem desktop ja
ich würde nicht zwangsläufig sagen man sollte sich unbedingt installieren auf
dem hauptrechner wie gesagt ich benutze linux auch täglich in der vm zum
arbeiten remote auf auf system und alles mögliche
muss es sich nicht gleich auf dem rechner installieren
sowieso das gefühl dass ich da erst an der oberfläche kratze ich habe zum
Beispiel noch gar nicht richtig die oberfläche getunt und tiefer gelegt und
so leute das beste was es jemals gab was oberfläche angeht ohne mist das mag
zwar heute cooler und besser designt aussehen aber oder nie cooler ist das
damals aus dass wisst ihr was das beste war was es je gegeben hat
oberflächen technisch das war zu den zeiten als kompens gerade voll abging
kompens war das beste leute
du konntest du konntest so viel blödsinn einstellen von abfackelten
fenstern zu würfeln auf dem desktop und so was
vieles gibt es heute mittlerweile auch ein bisschen seriöser eingebaut aber
kompens einfach geil und es ist schade dass kompens heute nicht mehr richtig
integriert ist es gibt zwar noch eine aktive kompens
entwicklung ab und zu mal kommt da was auf github
aber so wirklich gut verwenden kann man es heute nicht mehr und das ist doof
optisches zeugs geändert sondern einfach nur das hintergrund bild geändert
und dann noch mal kompens. ja das muss ich unbedingt mal ausprobieren.
jo hallo aus dem schnitt ich habe mir parallel zu kino auch endeavor os
installiert benutze aber kde plasma als desktop environment. da ich zum arbeiten
ausschließlich macOS benutze habe ich mir meinen desktop deutlich weniger lead designed
dafür schön clean das theme heißt Windsor und soll
wohl eine mischung aus windows und macOS sein das ging super easy über die kde
einstellung einfach erscheinungsbild globales design auf neues globales
design holen klicken und schon kann man sich die designs aus der community
herunterladen und mit einem klick anwenden mega entspannt genauso entspannt
ging das für die icons einfach design aussuchen herunterladen anwenden das
paket hier heißt cooloid für das lock am unteren bildschirmrand habe ich
plank installiert was ist das eigentlich für ein background latte und ja ich
weiß mit latte kann man sich auch sein eigenes dock einrichten das war aber so
komisch laggy was irgendwie ein problem mit kde und nvidia treibern zu sein
scheint beide elemente konnte ich einfach über die jeweiligen einstellungen der
tools in einer grafischen oberfläche so einstellen wie es mir gefällt nichts
mit kommando zeile oder so ach ja und richtig geil unter verhalten des
arbeitsbereichs arbeitsflächen effekte konnte ich mir die animation beim
schließen und öffnen der fenster aktivieren da gibt es zwar nicht super
war aber genau auch nicht trotzdem cool mein best terminal habe ich durch ein zsh
ausgetauscht und dazu noch das tool oh mein zsh installiert mit dem ding lässt
sich zsh nach belieben customisieren für das design hier bin ich einem
tutorial gefolgt was ich im internet gefunden habe der link ist in der
beschreibung alles in allem bin ich super gehyped über meinen zusammengebastelten
desktop erstens ging das viel einfacher als ich dachte zweitens finde ich es
einfach super schön deutlich schöner als windows auf jeden fall ja krass
schein so jetzt mein fazit ja linux auf dem desktop funktioniert ist super ist
gut ist das jetzt das ja des linux des tops weiß ich nicht ich glaube linux
auf dem desktop ist schon lange gut aber ich glaube jetzt mit der
zuverlässigen spielunterschützung wird das glaube ich tatsächlich für immer
mehr leute interessant und das was wir jetzt hier haben ist tatsächlich schon
eher was für leute die so ein bisschen lust auf basteln und das muss man auch
ganz klar sagen also jemand der sich einfach nur dahinsetzen will und gar
keinen bock hat sich mit dem system zu beschäftigen
der wird damit vielleicht auch glücklich wenn er nur ganz ganz basic
sachen machen will ja aber drüber hinaus ist es wirklich von vorteil man hat ein
bisschen bock drauf sich damit zu beschäftigen dann kann das viel besser
sein als windows gerade leute die ein bisschen was
customisieren wollen bisschen was bisschen was ihren vorstellungen anpassen
wollen da ist das für die bestimmt besser als windows und meck sofern hat
alles funktioniert was sie machen wollen ich habe ja auch ein eigenes video dazu
gemacht schon für leute die so ein leicht zu bedienendes schlüssel fertiges linux
haben wollen die sind vermutlich mit so was wie ubuntu oder mit genau bei allen
linuxen liegt ein vorteil gegenüber mac os und windows wirklich auf der hand
dass man quasi ewig updates bekommen auch wenn der rechner das stimmt das
stimmt mac os und windows gibt ja immer irgendwann den punkt an dem sich das
betriebssystem weiger zu updaten weil es die hardware nicht mehr unterstützen
will ja und dann muss man den rechner das problem ist es halt auch keine
sicherheitsupdates mehr gibt und so ein rechner will man ja nicht benutzen mit
linux passiert das nicht bis doll ja alles klar jetzt müssen wir bescheid
so ein neisser soundtrack
die drei motiviert ja das mal mehr mit der tastaturarbeit für viel ist das eine
große umstellung ob er dazu den rent gemacht hat keine ahnung ja das ist
für tatsächlich für bisschen umstellung wobei man ganz ehrlich sagen
muss ja es ist mehr tastatur zentriert aber ich mache trotzdem noch relativ
viel mit der maus das liegt einfach daran weil man ja zum größten teil auch
mal zwischen dem browser hin und her spricht und im browser der lässt sich
halt einfach am besten mit der maus bedienen bedient man den browser mit der
tastatur ich weiß dass es plugins gibt zum navigieren und so was mit
tastatur zentrierter bedienung von browser aber im ernst webseiten sind
visuell gedacht um sie mit der maus zu zu bedienen und ich habe es auch versucht
früher mich mit wie ist das in wie ist das in firefox das war nach irgendeinem
dinosaurier benannt zumindest hat es ähnliche namen gehabt wie so wie
dinosaurier gab es nun plugin mit wim bedienung für für firefox
cute browser gibt es auch noch das war schon ok das konnte man benutzen aber
ich bin da nie reingekommen ich finde webseiten lassen sich am besten mit
maus bedienen
und dementsprechend aber trotzdem öfters die maus in der hand was ich
halt schön finde bei i3 ist dass du die linke hand kannst lässt du an der
tastatur die rechte hand an der maus mit der linken hand kannst du in die drei
nahezu alles machen so wie ich es eingeschränkt du kannst desktop switchen
desktop switchen du kannst ein terminal hier teilen und so wie du willst
du kannst neue programme starten solche geschichten also dass ich habe das
eigentlich alles mit der linken hand ohne probleme machen kann
rechte rechte hand ist an der maus für browser oder vielleicht irgendwelche
sachen anklicken
ich finde so schlimm ist das gar nicht mehr tastatur bedienung
aber überhaupt mit homebrew aktualisierst du die software drauf und
nicht das betriebssystem selbst mit einem ordentlichen package manager unter
linux aktualisierst du ja das betriebssystem selbst und nicht nur die
drauf installierten packages
das ist ja der unterschied
ja schon spät das stimmt beginn ich gehe gleich ich gehe gleich pennen
demnächst
genau so mache ich das so mache ich das im prinzip auch ich mache eigentlich
halt nur die workspace steuerung über die tastatur also wenn ich mal wirklich
so sachen habe wie terminals wenn ich mal wirklich mehrere programme habe dann
ordne ich die auch hier per maus ja also wenn wir zum beispiel hier offen haben
plus den terminal das würde ich unbedingt brauchen man könnte auch das
eingebaute terminal nehmen ich habe hier so was offen das mache ich auch mit der
maus hier unten hin fertig aus aber man kann das man kann das machen mit
shortcuts und allem aber warum ich meine es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich das laufen
irgendwie ändern muss ich mache das einmal mit der maus da wo es hin soll
dann bleibt das so und der rest ist stelle ich mit der tastatur hier die
workspaces ein fertig ist das resizing mit der maus per default möglich in die
drei ja das geht feiert ihr auch us layout nee feier ich nicht du hast recht
so gerade was klammern angeht ist es nice aber ich habe kein bob mich um zu
gewöhnen andere andere tastatur layout
die meisten sachen sind ordentlich vorkonfiguriert ein paar sachen muss
zu machen ich kann sie aber gar nicht mehr aus dem kopf sagen was nur die fault ist
und was ich angepasst habe das weiß ich nicht mehr ich habe die die mappings
habe ich schon ziemlich lange so
ja genauso habe ich es auch deutsches tastatur layout ohne dead keys brauche
wirklich keiner
machst du das also ich kenne keinen wer das benutzt was sind dead keys zum
beispiel dass du diese taste hier zweimal drücken muss damit du das hier
bekommst guck sie musst du zweimal drücken
ja leute ich werde jetzt pennen gehen war schön dass sie heute abends am start
war wieder spontane geschichte morgen müssen wir mal gucken morgen machen wir
wahrscheinlich machen morgen machen wir mal irgendwas aus unserer aus unserer
to do liste ich habe noch eine viel längere to do liste vielleicht machen
wir vielleicht gucken wir uns tatsächlich mal wieder endeavor os an
weil wir es heute im video gesehen haben vielleicht gucken wir uns auch mal ein
paar server beispiele an kotlin machen wir morgen auf gar keinen fall auf java
habe ich keinen bock was ist jetzt servers das ist eine
übungsseite für linux admin skills da gibt es so ein paar aufgaben die man
lösen kann und dann wird am ende geguckt ob man sie richtig gelöst hat kann der
chat mitraten wobei das war das war sich auf die ersten blicken gesehen haben war
nicht sonderlich kompliziert
ich sporn alles klar weil ihr seid ja kann man so auch angucken kann auch auf
eure linux desktops reakt wenn ihr das wollt
könnt ihr könnt ihr screenshots ein schicken
ne nicht nicht wirklich capture the flag schon bisschen vielleicht schon eher an
so alltäglichen admin problemen so nach dem motto webserver schreibt ins log oder
webserver schreibt keine logs mehr woran liegt das rausfinden sowas ist das
discord ja im discord das könnten wir wirklich machen
rate rate mein linux desktop ein extra channel im im discord hot or not oder
sowas linux desktop
ich mache eben das ist eine gute idee und was für noch mal mit plus
kompets wollte ich mir mal angucken ob es das doch so cool ist wie man das
früher einstellen konnte alles da leute bis morgen wir sehen uns zu